ension
ah yeah...excellent, genau
Hat teams bestimmt wieder dran rumgestellt moment moment wir haben es gleich
Ja
So viel besser man weiß ja nicht so genau warum teams das macht aber teams macht das halt so
Erster exzellent. Jutsch. Leute soll ich euch mal was Pains Champiges erzählen?
Erstmal muss man jetzt entknoten kurz was dann zählt etwas Pains Champiges
So ich glaube so geht das halbwegs und zwar ich habe mir
weil nachdem ich ja letztens im stream ein paar boards gegrillt habe habe ich mir
Ein paar neue bestellt und zwar habe ich den Fehler gemacht das bei einem Ami Shop zu bestellen weil das am schnellsten ging
So hier habe ich bestellt
Und man kann im Checkout
So man kann im Checkout kann man auswählen
Dass die sich um die den Import und Zoll kümmern sollen Julian PSD Dankeschön für den Prime also man kann man kann auswählen dass die sich um den Zoll und Import Geschichten kümmern
Okay habe ich mir gedacht ey weißt du was?
Das Geld du musst ein bisschen was bezahlen weil
100 450 Euro mit Versand drüber und alles gut also habe ich das noch mal ausgewählt Leute ihr glaubt nicht wie
Unfähig nicht unbedingt die sind die können glaube ich gar nichts für sondern DHL express und der Zoll
Also habe bestellt und irgendwann morgens um halb acht oder so keine ahnung ich habe es ja mitgekriegt
Also ja um halb acht aber ich weiß nicht genau was sie wollten
Als angerufen und es war der Zoll leipzig das habe ich erst anhand der nummer erkannt
so
Das haben die haben sie nur dreimal klingeln lassen so schnell konnte ich gar nicht dran gehen also war weg also
Geht um die hier
Ich weiß nicht ob ich excellent express eher nicht es ist so und
So also da wusste etwas Sache ist also habe ich mal zurückgerufen
Also habe ich mal so jetzt leipzig wahrscheinlich weil die in leipzig aus den USA ankommen mit dem flieger
Ich glaube vermute ich mal dass es daran liegt
So Musiklautstärke passt denke ich Ticken Ticken leiser könnte man vielleicht machen
Na ja
So Zoll leipzig angerufen erst mal durch so ein komisches
Telefonmenü durchgeklickt dann habe ich rausgekriegt es war gar nicht der Zoll leipzig DHL hat da irgendwie eine station in
Kooperation mit dem zoll oder was auch immer und da hatte ich einen typ dran habe gesagt hier ihr habt angerufen ich vermute mal es geht
Um eine sendung aus den usa wusste ich ja nicht habe ich mal geraten habe ich ihm die sendungsnummer gegeben
Und da hatte ich einen typ dran der keinerlei englisch konnte und das internet ihm wohl auch relativ
Fremd ist ja
Da habe ich gesagt ok warum warum habt ihr denn angerufen was gibt es denn für unklarheiten
Da hat es die nummer nachgeguckt und mein so ja also das kann ich ihnen jetzt auch das war natürlich leipzig
Das kann ich ihnen jetzt auch nichts sagen
Und ja gut aber es muss ja grundgrundgrund gehabt haben warum ihr angerufen habt ja wahrscheinlich weil irgendwelche dokumenten fehlen
Ja, aber ich habe doch bei dem versender angekreuzt dass dhl express und der versender sich um den import
Kümmern soll man ja das kann sein dass wir da noch was wissen müssen ich gebe ihn mal eine uhr
Er hat nicht uhr gesagt zwar viel ich gebe ihn mal eine internet adresse oder so hat er gesagt und dann hat er
Vorgelesen jetzt ohne scheiß er hat vorgelesen
Http
Es
Backslash
Und aber ok jetzt
Jetzt vorbei
Na ja zumindest konnte er wahrscheinlich auch kein englisch weil genau das was die wohl wissen wollten nämlich was in dem paket drinne ist
das steht
das steht halt genau auf dem
auf dem beipackzettel vom vom her vom vom anbieter
das steht drauf
esp 32 circuit boards
Screens bla bla bla also steht genau drauf was drinne ist also ich meine halt irgendwelche platinen technik elektronik platinen kram
So was soll ich da großartig beschreiben na gut also das hat der typ schon mal nicht gecheckt also sprich für das dass ich extra geld bezahlt
Habt dass diese strom kümmern muss ich erst mal mit den telefonieren hat nichts gebracht bin ich auf die seite gegangen
Hab dhl rechnung und
Den titel von dem produkt hochgeladen was es gekostet hat
Und da dachte ich mir damit und auftrag angehakt dass sie es verzollen dürfen ok
Dann habe ich mir gedacht ok das war es jetzt sicherlich so irgendwann abends gucke ich in die mails habe ich eine email von dhl
Bekommen ich soll doch bitte meine meine zolldokumente hochladen
Mit einem link auf exakt die gleiche seite wo ich vier stunden vorher das schon hochgeladen habe
Das haben die wahrscheinlich einfach nicht gesehen
So und jetzt warte ich seit drei tagen dass ich was update ich vermute mal die haben einfach das nicht bekommen und denken jetzt
Sie warten auf mich
So und ein sage ich wenn die mir jetzt noch ankommen mit lager gebühren das bezahle ich nicht
Ich rufe da am montag noch mal an einmal ganz im ärzt das kann doch nicht sein dass ich zweimal was hochladen muss wovon ich einmal was hochgeladen habe
Und mindestens zweimal mit denen telefonieren muss für einen service den komplett der hersteller
Und der versanddienstleister machen sollten oder ich habe dich schon auf twitter angeschrieben haben gesagt ich soll mich an die support wenden ich müsste es vielleicht öffentlich machen ja
Ich meine das kann doch nicht sein kettenpeng langsinn für den sub fünf monat exzellent subscriptions hier es kann doch nicht sein
Warum du dich in china bestellt das weil es den kram nicht in china gibt das ist ein hersteller aus den usa
Und ich habe hier letztens im stream moment ich zeigst dir wenn ich dabei war
Zwei boards gekillt eins eins off stream und eins und stream
Hier schön moment moment moment top 30 smoke es muss relativ weit oben sein smoke
Was sonst
top 30 smoke es muss relativ weit oben sein smoke was sonst da wo was kaputt geht das wird natürlich gevotet
So es hat es hat geraucht es hat übrigens nicht da geraucht es hat hier geraucht ist da hochgezogen
Habt ihr gesehen es raucht und damit war das Board kaputt
So und davor Offstream durch den billigen China Spannungswandler
Durch den billigen China Spannungswandler habe ich schon mal ein Board kaputt gemacht davor
Offstream und ich hatte insgesamt nur fünf und drei Stück sind also jetzt eins habe ich jetzt noch
zum basteln und zwei Stück sind also insgesamt quasi drei Stück verbaut und jetzt habe ich mir
einfach neue bestellt und die kriegen es halt echt nicht gebacken das ist echt der Wahnsinn echt für
den Arsch. Übrigens soll ich euch mal wir haben ja wir haben letztens im Stream Massive C++ Proggers
gemacht und ich musste kotzen Leute ich habe es wieder voll übertrieben ich habe es voll übertrieben
ich soll ich euch mal zeigen wie das wieder aktuelle wieder aktuelle Stromzähler Ausläs
Microcontroller aussieht ich habe es voll übertrieben ich zeige euch mal ein paar Bilder
ich habe extra ein paar Bilder gemacht vorher ich habe es voll übertrieben
auf 20 Zeilen nein nein ich habe irgendwie 800 Zeilen also natürlich Bock
also als erstes mal so die Gesamtübersicht
ok das sagt Open Image ok jetzt sieht man ein bisschen was also erste mal alles ordentlich
Kabel drum herum gemacht nicht einfach nur billige Jumperkabel so richtig echte Kabel
für alle Sensoren Gehäuse 3D gedruckt das ist der Sensor für den Stromzähler das ist
der Temperaturluftfeuchtigkeitssensor und das ist der Sensor für den Stromzähler oben den
habe ich schon zugemacht also für alles 3D Gehäuse gedruckt aus einem alten Lightning Kabel brauche
ich eher zu viele ordentliche Kabel noch dran gemacht alles alles schön verlötet dann was
auch nice ist alle Sachen verschrumpfschlaucht ja gut ob man das jetzt so macht sei mal dahingestellt
alle Sachen verschrumpfschlaucht mit ich habe so ein Spezial Spezialdings gekauft das sind
Schrumpfschläuche plus Lötzinn in einem die sind echt Poggers die ziehst du so drum
machst du mit dem Feuerzeug warm dann dann verlöten die die Drähte und Schrumpfschlauchen
drum herum das ist richtig geil das Zeug hätte ich am Anfang gar nicht gedacht
gucken ob es da so was hier genau solche Teile sind das die sind echt Poggers ich weiß nicht
ob die im Beispiel genau ok guck du schiebst du schiebst hier die Kabel rein und dann machst
ein Feuerzeug dran oder so eine Heißluft Pistole und das schrumpft den Schlauch und schmilzt
das Lötzinn zusammen also das ist super super zackig richtig nice so alles schön zusammen
gemacht so und hier sieht man glaube ich wo das Ding an ist das was an ist das ist zum
auslesen von meinem Stromzähler im Keller guck das ist noch bevor ich es reingepackt
habe ich glaube ich habe noch was wo ich von oben einmal reinfotografiert habe genau hier
habe ich von oben mal reinfotografiert das ist eigentlich das ist alles relativ ordentlich
gemacht so und hier vorne hast du halt das Display was du eigentlich gar nicht brauchst
weil ich dran gemacht habe weil es cool ist genau hier oben hast du noch Temperatur Luftfeuchtigkeit
weil es cool aussieht und halt das was die Stromzähler gemessen haben so aber Leute
das was richtig anstrengend war wo ich es voll übertrieben habe jetzt pass mal auf
ich habe ein Webinterface für das Ding gebaut doch ich habe die im Stream mal ausgesucht
ich habe ein Webinterface für das Ding gebaut das wollte ich nämlich schon lange mal machen
für alle meine ESP32s dass ich ein ordentliches Webinterface habe wo ich das läuft auf dem
Controller das läuft auf dem Mini Controller was ihr gerade seht also das ist ein Webinterface
da kannst du Updates machen sowohl Filesystem als auch Firmware du kannst eine LED an und
ausschalten wenn du nicht genau weißt welcher Controller es ist da leuchtet es gelb an und
aus du kannst das Ding neu starten du hast die wichtigsten Infos auf einen Blick was
man so braucht also Speicher, wann es gestartet ist, Uptime, wie viel Filesystem Speicher
noch da ist und die einzigartige ID du kannst die du kannst das WLAN ändern NLCS Dankeschön
und du hast eine Konsole die auch Sachen ausführt also ich habe da noch keine Kommandos drin
das antwortet immer nur im Standardkommando aber das funktioniert das geht alles über
Websockets also es war echt das 800 Zeilen lang das Web also das Backend für das Webinterface
800 Zeilen C++ ihr könnt euch vorstellen wie ich gelitten habe Alter das ist schon
nice oder?
Das hier müsst ihr übrigens noch volle Größe machen achja und wisst ihr was das
Beste ist die Seite ist auch noch responsive guckt mal responsive Seite das WLAN hier
massive responsiveness so nice das ist Tailwind unten drunter weil das haben wir letztens
im Stream ausprobiert weil Tailwind wenn du nicht viele Klassen verwendest echt klein
ist also das gesamte Webinterface ist 42 Kilobyte ungefähr das Webinterface liegt auf dem zusätzlichen
Flash das ist nicht in der Firmware drin das ist 42 Kilobyte als Gzip
der Preis ist kaputt gerade habe ich heute morgen gesehen den müsste ich mal neu starten
kann ich aber gerade nicht machen von hier aus
Nee HTTPS mache ich nicht das habe ich vor einer Weile mal gemacht das braucht so viel
Speicher das funktioniert leider nicht gescheit auf dem ESP32 und auf dem ESP866 das rechnet
auf dem ESP866 kriegst du genau eine HTTPS Connection das heißt zu irgendwer achja übrigens
ihr seht auch das updatet sich über Websockets also das updatet sich live sowohl wie gut
der WLAN Empfang ist als auch die Uptime und sowas also das überträgt alle 5 Sekunden
den aktuellen Stand ja also das funktioniert nicht mit HTTPS ich habe das probiert auf
dem ESP32 das schickt dir ein Home Assistant PMQTT mein Zeug funktioniert alles schon
ich habe das probiert das Problem ist du hast ja insgesamt hier hast du ich weiß gar nicht
ob man das wirklich voll nutzen kann also du hast 322 Kilobyte an Speicher an RAM quasi
was du nehmen kannst für dein laufendes Programm das Problem ist dass eine HTTPS Connection
egal ob das jetzt ein Webrequest ist oder eine Websocket Verbindung Websocket Verbindung
ist natürlich noch schlimmer weil die ist dauerhaft braucht 40 bis 60 Kilobyte also
vergiss es du kriegst maximal 4-5 Connections HTTPS auf dem ESP32 dass dein RAM komplett
voll ist und dein Sketch eventuell noch irgendwie läuft ne eigentlich auch nicht das bringt
nichts also wenn ich das mit HTTPS machen würde was übrigens gar nicht so einfach
ist weil der eingebaute also die Web Server die dabei sind es gar nicht können deswegen
habe ich ja meinen eigenen Web Server gebastelt für das Ding was HTTPS kann wenn das das
machen würde dann wäre ich jetzt wäre der RAM voll allein schon für die Web Requests
ich meine ich mache ein Web ich mache Requests für die Seite und ich mache Requests für
die Wi-Fi Infos und ich habe einen standardmäßig aktiven Websocket also allein schon das der
werde ich bei 300 Kilobyte RAM wir reden übrigens nicht von Megabit für den Kilobyte RAM also
der Shit hier wo hängt er denn da wow was ist das für Musik das ist Bowser Fight ja
kann ich übertreiben ja besser das Teil hier hat halt nur 300 Kilobyte RAM so exzellent
so sieht es aus ja das habe ich gemacht die letzten Tage und jetzt muss ich es eigentlich
nur noch einbauen so jetzt gucke ich mal kurz Chat was ich übersehen habe
Freeder Röck Twitch Prime Dankeschön für den Sub
mehr RAM auflöten ne du wirst lachen es gab Leute die haben versucht nicht ich glaube
nicht mehr doch du kannst du kannst RAM anbinden über
SPI du musst aber irgendwie habe ich letztes gelesen im Forum du musst den den den Chip
ablöten und dann irgendwelche zwei Sachen anlöten den Chip wieder drauflöten dann
kannst du irgendwie bis zu ich glaube sogar bis zu 4 MB oder so zusätzlich RAM machen
aber das funktioniert auch nicht richtig weil der Chip nicht genug Speichel ach keine Ahnung
ist für den Arsch also besser man bleibt mit dem was Build-in ist
wahrscheinlich schon aber wenn es nicht reicht dann hast ja nicht viel Wahl
kannst dann 40 hast dann RAM über irgendeinen 40 Mhz Bus angeboten ist bestimmt
huge schnell also kannst du beim nein kann ich nicht
weil das Problem beim Preischamp ist ich kann eigentlich nur die Sachen nehmen die standardmäßig
Tracker drin sind aber gerade dabei sind muss mal kurz schauen ob es Updates für den Tracker
gibt weil er kann ich mal den Tracker updaten haben die haben die deutsche Shops geupdatet
in letzter Zeit das muss man nachgucken dann lohnt sich das nämlich fix Playstation Walmart
ist mir egal Micro Center AMD Asus mir auch egal
Media Markt Saturn Note ok das ist gut das Moment 22 Februar ist der Preischamp nicht
sogar neuer Changelog ne 1.2 da hab ich zuletzt was gemacht ok nice dann ist die 360 für
Saturn Notebooks billiger drin ist schon mal gut Global Data juckt mich nicht
Best Buy ist mir auch egal Kanada Computers juckt mich auch nicht PC Digger was ist das
denn?
PC Digger alter ne es ist anscheinend keine alternate und mine factory Sachen dabei
ne ja dann werde ich es mal updaten aber das ist gar nicht mal so unbedingt jetzt super
dringend ja das hab ich schon alles hier ah gut ich muss aber mal nachher die Crawler
neu starten weil irgendwie ist grad außer Notebooks billiger funktioniert nix mehr
scheint irgendwie gecrashed zu sein oder so kein Schimmer also wie gesagt ich kann nur
das einbauen ich hab die Switch ja schon zusätzlich eingebaut aber die funktioniert auch nicht
richtig also Pflegeaufwand technisch ich kann bloß das einbauen was der Crawler kann
ich kanns ja nicht mal abholen in Leipzig die kriegens nicht gebacken zolltechnisch
würdest du Raspberry Pi Komponenten einzeln kaufen oder den kompletten Set wenn du genug
hast würd ich einzeln kaufen also ich hab beispielsweise viel zu viele Raspberry Pi
von diesen Billig Raspberry Pi Gehäusen hab ich viel zu viel weil ich zu viele Sets gekauft
hab Passivkühler hab ich auch genug bei Netzteile ja das ist das einzige aber ganz ehrlich es
tut auch ein billiges USB Kabel und USB Netzteil die Sache ist die wenn du Raspberry Pi 3 hast
und den voll auslustest dann gibt es Probleme dann sagt er er bekommt zu wenig Power aus
seinem Netzteil aber nachdem das die wenigsten machen ist das kein großes Ding ja aber das
Problem ist die Sets sind meistens relativ teuer guck mal wenn du da Sets guckst da bezahlst
du 90 Euro ok das der Raspberry Pi 4 ist auch so relativ teuer guck mal wenn du hier einen
Raspberry Pi 4 kaufen willst der kostet ja auch schon 60 Dollar oder sowas glaub ja 60
Euro also 60 Euro für den Raspberry Pi oder 70 sogar das heißt du hast auch 20 Euro dabei
aber ganz ehrlich der restliche Kram der dabei hey das ist gar nicht das Gehäuse ist sogar
ganz gut glaube ich also das kann man machen aber wobei es ist halt viel unsinniger Krams
dabei ne Lüfter ganz ehrlich ich wird Passiv gekühlt machen das Gehäuse mit Lüfter wird
ich mir nicht kaufen es gibt es gibt ein paar ganz gute Passiv Gehäuse die die nicht so
teuer sind also du kannst es gibt auch noch ein paar günstigere aber das ist so das das
beste finde ich und da bist du dann bist du quasi auch bei 80 Euro wenn du dir das Case
plus den Raspberry Pi 4 kaufst gibt es einen Pi mit 4G nein gibt es nicht du kannst aber
natürlich ein USB 4G Dings dran machen das ist ja das gute an dem das ist das gute am
Raspberry Pi gegenüber irgendeinem Arduino oder ESP ist das halt ein vollwertiges Linux
drauf läuft und du ordentlich viele die Fortschnittstellen hast wohingegen Sachen über GPIOs und halt
Real-Time Sachen mit einem ESP deutlich einfacher sind als mit dem Raspberry Pi ist halt wenigstens
wenn du USB brauchst oder ein bisschen was ausgefallenes verwenden willst also ist halt
richtig ist das Gold wert dass du ein Standard Linux drauf hast mit USB brauchst du wirklich
USB G? Nee brauchst du nicht also 2G ist ok der alte hatte nur 1G 2G ist ok ich hab halt
immer den mit 4 genommen ich glaube ich hab mittlerweile sogar einen 8er da weil es geht
eigentlich brauchst du es nicht 2G reicht 2G reicht auch ja so was wird heute gemacht
wir gucken uns gleich ein paar Videos an wir wachen auf ich bin hier wir sind bloß gerade
irgendwie auf Raspberry Pi Sets gekommen also das würde ich mir wahrscheinlich nicht
kaufen das kannst du dir kaufen mal angenommen das ist dein erstes Set was du dir holst und
du hast kein Problem damit dass es ein aktiv was wird der immer mehr hört dir gar nicht
mehr auf dass es ein aktiv gekühltes Gehäuse ist dann kannst du dir das kaufen würde ich
aber nicht machen also ich würde mir wahrscheinlich einen Pi 4 kaufen ja gut ist der 8G gibt's
auch den 4G 2G haben wir den auch da gibt's hier gar nicht zu kaufen ja der 4G kostet
60 ja also ich würde den ich würde wie gesagt ich würde den 2G kaufen was gibt's noch für
schöne früher gab's Pi Meroni unsere Berry Base gab's noch die kommen aber alle aus
England jetzt und das sagt Kosten der neu 2G wow wait a minute warte mal warte mal warte
mal ist so teuer ah ne ok aber trotzdem warte mal 2 Euro na ok ja ist in Ordnung ich hab
nichts gesagt also 40 Euro ist auch ok also du kaufst du 40 Euro und ich würde dir halt
empfehlen kauf dir entweder gar kein Case also es gibt zwei Varianten entweder nimmst
du gar kein Case und sagst ich benutze das Ding eh nicht so dass es großartig warm wird
du kannst das du dass das offical Case finde ich jetzt persönlich kacke das Ding das ist
zwar billig dass das offical Case ich hab ich ich hab mich ich hab geantwortet Hetzner
ja aber ich vermute mal dass diejenigen die geschrieben hat kann im Urlaub ist oder so
oder ich hoffe mal nicht Corona weil die haben noch nicht mehr geantwortet ich warte mal
nächste Woche ab also ich fände es halt echt geil wenn ich irgendwie so ein bisschen Hetzner
Cooperation mache ich mach so viel Werbung für die also das ich also ich mag das offizielle
Case nicht ich bin der Meinung gar kein Case oder oder oder sowas äh Moment oder sowas
du kannst das war das offizielle Case das würde ich nur verwenden wenn deine Frau Freundin
Mutter wer auch immer sagt ah ich kann keine offene Elektronik sehen da krieg ich Anfälle
das muss in ein Gehäuse rein dann würde ich das offizielle Case nehmen aber ansonsten
aber ansonsten würde ich das Ding einfach oben stehen lassen offen stehen lassen ja
Friesen Returns ist das die Stimme von Max FPS wie kommst du da drauf das kann kann
ich sein nein nein der Avatar verrät mich ja auch gar nicht aber nice dass du den Weg
hierher gefunden hast den ESP mit PS2 ja das habe ich noch offen auf dem Schirm also wie
gesagt würde ich nicht kaufen und die Sets würde ich auch nicht kaufen ich würde mir
eine Raspberry Pi 4 kaufen am besten das 2G Modell wenn man nicht viel Geld ausgeben
will das Flier Case dabei und äh ja wenn wenn es unbedingt also das das das das Beste
an diesen Sets ist tatsächlich noch das Netzteil weil man hat man hat meistens keine 3 keine
5,1 Volt 3 Ampere Netzteile rumliegen jetzt mein 5 5 Volt 2 tut es auch ja aber wenn man
auf Nummer sicher gehen will dass der auch unter absolut Volllast alle vier Kerne Grafikkarte
volle Pulle noch genug Strom kriegt das offizielle Netzteil ist das einzig sinnvoll eigentlich
bei diesen oder dass das das Netzteil was bei diesen Sets dabei ist eigentlich das
einzig sinnvolle äh was was es gibt aber das kannst du dir auch so kaufen aber brauchst
du nicht aber brauchst du nicht äh es tut auch ein normaler Charger es tut ja genau
es tut auch ganz normaler Charger und USB C Kabel nee Smart Mirror finde ich irgendwie
total sinnlos weiß ich nicht brauch ich nicht ich hab mein Tablet ich hab meine Dashboards
im Flur hängen das reicht mir übrigens ich hab jetzt was richtig nicees gebaut ich hab
so einen so einen Switch hier gekauft vor einer Weile das ist ein Zigbee Zigbee Switch mit
so einem magnetischen Halter also sprich den kann man auch Alter ich hab irgendwas im Hals
was ist denn heut los so oder was anderes im Hals Lul die Argon Cases sind auch gut aber
die sind die die größeren sind mir ein bisschen zu teuer für den Raspberry Pi Dankeschön
Luthorax für den Sub exzellent Subscription schön das der welche her gefunden hast Massive
die Dashboards im Flur die zeigen mein Home Assistant Dashboard an das sind Fire TV äh
nicht Fire TV äh Fire HD 10s zwei Stück und die hängen direkt neben der Gegensprecherlage
von der Tür da kann dann geht dann auch immer die Kamera an der Tür auf wenn es klingelt
ja äh genau also ich hab mir ich hab mir so ein so ein 6 Wege Zigbee Switch gekauft
vor einer Weile schon ich hab jetzt endlich einen sinnvollen Anwendungszweck für also
dieses Ding hier hinten ist magnetisch das hält zum Beispiel am Türrahmen und ich hab's
jetzt so gemacht ich hab ähm das bei mir hier ans Arbeitszimmer an die Tür gemacht
ich hab's bisher nur zwei Buttons gemapped ich hab das oben links gemacht für zum testen
für Deckenlicht an aus Deckenlicht an aus aber kein Problem das kann ich über den normalen
Schalter in der Wand machen ähm also das bräuchte ich gar nicht mal unbedingt aber
Deckenlicht an aus hab ich hier drauf und auf dem zweiten Schalter hab ich deswegen
hab ich das auch dahingehängt weil ich mir gedacht hab das ist ein richtig cooles Anwendungsgebiet
ich hab auf dem zweiten Schalter so ein alles ausgemacht da drück ich jetzt mal angenommen
ich hab hier ähm meine Bastelbeleuchtung an also ich hab hier mein Ringlight Basteltisch
wo man manchmal Streamson von äh das Ringlight die Fensterbeleuchtung das Deckenlicht und
theoretisch sogar den PC könnte ich auch damit machen und wenn ich abends hier drauf drücke
dann geht alles auf einen Schlag aus und das hier toggelt nur das Deckenlicht also sprich
wenn ich abends ins Bett geh und hab vorher noch irgendwas gebastelt dann geh ich einfach
aus dem Arbeitszimmer raus drück den Knopf es geht alles aus äußerst nice Kill Switch
ja wobei ich mir überlegt habe ich werde das noch ein wenig verbessern und zwar werd
ich nicht Press machen sondern Long Press weil ansonsten stell dir mal vor ich mach
da auch noch ähm ich mach da auch noch den PC und alles dran und ich hab einfach nur
normalen Press und ich geh mal aufs Klo und komm da irgendwie dabei dann fährt ja alles
runter das ist ja doof das würde ich nicht machen deswegen ich stelle das um ich stelle
das um auf auf Long Press oder vielleicht sogar Triple Press was meint ihr ist besser
Triple Press oder Long Press ich glaub sogar Triple Press weil Triple Press machst du
nicht mal aus Versehen wenn du d d d also wenn du Triple Press machst dann ähm ja
exzellent exzellent so also erst mal fancy ja ok oh was denn das Kokona Style jawoll
Windows Update Zorgwärm ist das eigentlich gefixt das eigentlich gefixt das beim Drucken
das beim Drucken Blue Screen kommt ja das ist gefixt oder wie viel Gigahertz schafft
der der Bauer PC Ober PC Welt gehst mal fort ich guck mir gern den den Bauer an aber aber
PC Welt muss nicht sein how to Twitch chat gachi emote jawoll Bacon Burger Bacon Strips
Bacon Strips hat der Bauer irgendwas neues der Auer ist bestimmt Sponsored auch verstehen
Twitch auch machen BioWare am Ende hab ich das warum ist Baum ist BioWare am Ende hab
ich nicht hab ich nicht das gleiche Video schon offen ah ne echt ist BioWare warum
ist BioWare weg hä hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt der Preis Chem ist gerade anscheinend sind
die Crawler abgekackt der hat gerade außer Notebooks billiger nicht drin das muss ich
nachher mal neu starten aber es kann auch sein dass es einfach der Link zum Shop nicht
drin ist es ist aktuell anscheinend geht nur der Notebooks billiger Crawler aktuell ja
machst du nix ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht neu starten aber die Preise sind echt nicht
mal feierlich ich hab letztens den Schnapper schlecht hingesehen für 3900 Euro OC 3090
auf Amazon Otto geht auch noch macht es da nicht Sinn den Preis Chem nächtlich neu zu
starten ja eigentlich haste nicht unrecht ja könnte man machen der hält aber meistens
so ne Woche oder so und dann kackt er ab das liegt aber nicht an meinem Frontend das liegt
an dem Crawler der irgendwie den Abgang macht nach einer Weile ja das Problem ist an der
3060 solang der Crawler das nicht kann bringt mir das nix dann kann ich das nicht anzeigen
ich hab versucht die Switch da selbst einzubauen das klappt auch nicht richtig
ne der läuft nicht mehr in einem Docker Container weil aber warum warum lief da nicht mehr ich
hatte den ursprünglichen Docker Container laufen macht er jetzt nicht mehr weil er ja klar weil
ich ein paar custom Anpassungen gemacht habe und es war mir zu ätzen da immer noch den
Docker Container zu bilden bei jeder bei jeder Anpassung ich habe ein paar custom Sachen gemacht
dass es besser sich integrieren lässt Toxie Dankeschön für den Sub 14 Monate das ist ja
schon Hypersubscription und das einfache ist beim automatischen Aufbau das nicht in
Docker Container zu machen so ich wollte noch ganz schnell den Chat fertig durchgehen also
wie gesagt das haben jetzt ausführlich beantwortet wie gesagt ich würde es einzeln kaufen es
sei denn das ist das aller aller allererste Raspberry Pi den ich kaufen würde da kann
man sich vielleicht ein Set kaufen aber ansatzweise würde ich mir die eher einzeln kaufen wie
gesagt er PS geht nicht braucht so viel Rahmen wie gesagt mit das habe ich mit Tailwind gemacht
weil ich letzter Zeit nur ein bisschen Tailwind angeguckt habe und ich ja bisher immer gedacht
habe das braucht kein Mensch kann ich einfach inline CSS schreiben ist im Prinzip ja auch
ähnlich aber trotzdem angenehmer gerade mit Autocomplete und allem ja genau daran lag
das ich hoffe du machst ich hoffe du machst nicht einfach nur schleifen sondern du machst
if schleifen das ist tatsächlich so ne also ich habe bisher alles was ich aus den USA
bestellt habe hat nicht funktioniert über den Zoll gescheit die Kona Leute sind entweder
nicht in der Lage das ordentlich zu kennzeichnen oder der Zoll und DHL ist nicht in der Lage
Perfax, ja, Alter die Musik was ist denn jetzt los?
es passiert hier wunderbar Wunder gerade extrem epische Dinger
bei den Leuten wird mich da nichts wundern wie gesagt als er die Domain vorgelesen hat
mit Backslash Backslash da dachte ich mir schon ach du Scheiße wo bin ich denn da gelandet
weil ihr wisst ja das hier ist eigentlich ein Backslash ne ok nice wir haben alles
ich hoffe wir haben alles haben wir alles der Heiz Champ ja ihr wisst ja das mein das das
Ding ihr wisst wie das heißt oder wie das Projekt heißt
der Watt Champ was sonst genau der nicht der Zähl Champ der Watt Champ
was klick mal auf das Kamera Icon in der Taskleiste da gibt es kein ist das he doesn't know he
lacks critical information das da oder was als Nachfolger KW Champ ne dann lieber Zähl
Champ Toxy Dankeschön für den Sub exzellent ne bei dem Defender Icon wo ist denn hier
überhaupt ein Defender Icon das da was ist das meet now
brauche kein Mensch ok nice also was schauen wir uns den jetzt mal an exquisite ne da komm
wir fangen mal mit ne switch to the was gucken wir uns den grafikkarten so teuer eine Erklärung
gerne minimiert oder ähnliches wird kein Bild angezeigt aber das ist ja er hätte sich
auch mal vor die Kamera stellen können Anthem Bioware größte Niederlage
warum hab ich ein Corona Video auf ich will eigentlich gar kein Corona Video gucken aber
was wieder geil ist ne die Bewertung die Bewertung ja wisst ihr was ich echt doof finde bei der
Corona Geschichte dass das Wort Querdenker zu was negativen geworden ist
also früher war das Wort Querdenker ja eher was positives aber seit Corona ist Querdenker
irgendwas wo die Leute sagen OMG Querdenker lull
übrigens jetzt wo ich es hier gerade sehe wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an ich wollte
das eigentlich gar nicht aufmachen aber jetzt wo ich es gerade sehe
also man muss ja echt sagen die schaffen es gerade schaffen es gerade wirklich alle
möglichen Leute Leute zu verwirren ne ich war ja immer dafür ich hab auch gesagt ey
sobald man sich impfen lassen kann lass mich impfen dann ist Ruhe aber irgendwann mit
ihrem hin und her und immer die Leute ich will mal nicht sagen na doch an lügen kann man
sagen aber die schaffen es doch irgendwann dass ich mich dann mal impfen lassen will
es ist echt der Wahnsinn ich weiß nicht was die da treiben wieder aktuell na doch ich
lass mich schon impfen aber das hin und her also ich mein man muss sich mal überlegen
man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen also das Handling und das Management
das Sache ist wirklich echt unter aller Kanone man muss sich mal überlegen man muss sich
mal überlegen dass wartet mal kurz genau also genau was ich sagen wollte also die haben
ja diesen Impfstoff der nicht so einen guten Ruf hat und da hieß es zuerst den soll man
nicht an ältere impfen weil man sich genau weiß was passiert ok also alles über alles
überfahrt mir nicht 70 plus oder 60 plus solltet ihr nicht bekommen sondern den anderen
habe ich mir gedacht ok klingt ja sinnvoll so dann zwei drei Wochen später haben sie
gesagt ah nee nee Gehirnblutung sonst was wir impfen gar nicht mehr und jetzt kam die
Empfehlung jetzt wo man wieder impft mit dem also scheiß auf Gehirnblutung jetzt wo man
den wieder impft jetzt gibt es die Empfehlung dass man ihn nur noch für ältere verwenden
soll das mag ja alles einen sinnvollen Grund haben aber den muss man mal ordentlich erklären
weil normalerweise leuchtet also hier leuchtet das jetzt nicht ein warum man den vorher auf
keinen Fall an ältere machen sollte jetzt gestoppt hat und jetzt nur an ältere oder
hauptsächlich auch an ältere oder what the fuck keine Ahnung dazu kommt dazu kommt dass
man den Leuten am Anfang Mist erzählt hat so von wegen Masken wirken nicht weil man
den Engpass vermeiden wollte was ja auch sagen wir mal ein ehrenwertes Ziel war aber trotzdem
Leute angeschwindelt waren und danach hat man sich überlegt die Corona Standort also
wo man eintragen musste an welchem Standort man ist ist rein zweckgebunden aber da kam
die bayerische Polizei und hat gesagt ach nee doch nicht ja keine Ahnung also das Handling
der Sache ist nicht so optimal ja
es ist irgendwie nicht ganz nachvollziehbar für normalsterbliche Leute dann müsste das
halt auch man müsste jetzt mal kann das hier alles machen und ich ich würde den noch nicht
mal unterstellen dass sie das ohne komplett ohne plan machen vieles passiert wahrscheinlich
auch ohne plan aber sei mal hingestellt aber man muss es ordentlich er muss das schon ordentlich
erklären warum das so ist man kann nicht einfach sagen irgend einer hat gesagt das ist so und
das machen wir jetzt deswegen so so muss das schon erklären warum das so ist mag sein
dass das irgendwie passiert ist an irgendwelche Stellen wo ich mitgekriegt habe aber da muss
man sich nicht wundern wenn wenn man komplett das Vertrauen verspielt ja bei so gerade bei
so hin und her muss du musst du das ordentlich musst du das alles ordentlich erklären und
begründen aber das kriegen sie nicht gebacken und deswegen gibt es auch immer mehr leute
die panik schieben wegen infok ich war letztens beim doktor ich weiß gar nicht ob ich euch
zu euch erzählt habe habe ich euch erzählt die eine die im wartezimmer geheult hat wegen
corona das habe ich euch gar erzählt oder also ich muss letztens zum doktor weil ich
die da wo ich so drei vier tage so viel kopfweh hatte muss ich letztens zum doktor gehen
um mir eine krankmeldung holen und da war ich im wartezimmer und ich hatte ich schon
übels kopfweh das du kannst nicht abhaben wenn leute rumschreien so und da saß ich
da drin es waren auch plus zwei drei leute drin das war wirklich wenig wenig los alle
mit maske auf alles gut und dann steht da kommt eine an die rein reingewetzt und so und da
kommt eine reingewetzt meint sie will sich impfen lassen gegen corona beziehungsweise
wenn es noch nicht geht dann will sie einen termin haben ja dachte ich mir so kann sie
kann sie ja machen dann meint die sprechstunden hilfe irgendwie ja das ist noch nicht klar
ob sie das impfen dürfen und wann das losgeht und hat die übelst angefangen zu heulen weil
sie was ist denn heute los da hat die übelst angefangen rum zu heulen und rumzuschreien
im wartezimmer weil sie permanent eine maske aufhaben muss und das findet sie so anstrengend
permanent eine maske aufzuhaben und sie kann die maske aber auch nicht auf ausziehen weil
sie hat so viel angst corona zu bekommen und sie ist nervlich total am ende die ging voll
ab die lag dann später halb auf dem boden meine güte und ich hab ich sitze da mit übelst
kopf im wartezimmer und ich denke mir einfach die klappe die hat ja gerade mit mir geredet
aber das ging mir schon massiv auf den sack also man sieht es stecken nicht alle leute
so gut weg manche leute oder viele leute wahrscheinlich sogar sind in der aktuellen zeit wirklich
ziemlich am ende ja und ich und ich sitze halt hier ich setze ich sitze halt hier und
denke mir so hauptsache hauptsache noch ein bisschen länger corona für länger dauer
home office aber die meisten leute denken sich eher kein quake wann gehts wieder los
ja und logistisch kriegen sie es ja auch irgendwie nicht gebacken ne ach keine ahnung ich war
mir da ehrlich gesagt gar keine gedanken drüber ich lasse mich impfen wenn es soweit ist und
vorher mache ich das was ich was ich eh am besten kann wenig kontakt zu real life leuten
und vom rechner setzen und zeug machen exzellent müssen übrigens die emotes verschieben die
müssen dahin so also was gucken wir jetzt was schauen wir uns jetzt an 7 linux things
you say wrong okay you're saying wrong zeit mal her ok ok es ist es ist es ist genug es
ist gut es ist was heißt genu genu genu wie spricht man das überhaupt aus ich habe keinen
schimmer gnu gnu ok gnu gnu ein bisschen lauter mal gnu ist actually pronounced gnu
gnu habe ich doch richtig gesagt das heißt das ist glaubt das heißt gnom heißt das
nicht gnom warum im hochformat na weil es schwarz ist
gnom gnom ist es ok ok das wissen wir damit kennen wir uns aus es heißt nicht jubantu
es heißt auch nicht jubantu tschubu oder tschubantu es heißt ubuntu
ubuntu genau ubuntu es gibt ja sogar ein video wo nelson mandela höchst persönlich ubuntu
sagt auf youtube und irgendwelche typen haben den ubuntu logo da reingemacht was damit überhaupt
nix zu tun hat ok ja hier guck nelson explain warum ist da ein fucking ubuntu warum ist da
ein ubuntu logo drin das hat mit der linux distribution überhaupt nix zu tun alter na gut
wenn sie meinen und das heißt ubuntu aber ehrlich wenn man sich so afrikanische sprachen
anguckt ubuntu klingt doch deutlich afrikanischer als tschubantu oder jubantu ubuntu das ist
debian debian debian ok das dachte ich dass das mate heißt ich das war ich mir ziemlich
sicher dass das mate heißt et like a pirate say mate like mate ernsthaft ach du scheiße
da wäre ich ja nie drauf gekommen mate ok das kann doch keiner erwarten dass man das
instinktiv weiß oder
ja du bist da du musst einfach nur warten also es gibt genug leute ja auch schon im stream
gesagt haben sie haben den ganzen pc sich da drüber zusammengestellt muss halt ein
bisschen mehr bezahlen was willst du machen da kann ich ja nix für moment wie heißt
das ok sudo dachte schon dass das sudo heißt sudo ok das ist mir zu blöd
ich sag weiter sudo ich ich weiß von was es steht aber von der aussprache her
ok was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an wie dieser hacker das internet gerettet
hat dass ibaro ist da 21 monate das ja exzellente hyper subscriptions
dass ibaro ist da der cute mod himself ist wieder am start
wunderbar was macht das leer am grill wo wir gerade dabei sind die besten themen öffentlich
im stream zu besprechen natürlich so wo sind wir stehen diese hacker wo war das denn jetzt
schreibt nicht zurück was soll das denn schreibt nicht so das ist trick das ist das ist das
ist grilltrick siebaro mit dem nicht zurückschreiben ich will wahrscheinlich gucken die wahrscheinlich
gucken wie du reagierst wie ist der link von maxpreistoolpreischamp.org aber die crawlers
sind gerade kaputt die muss ich später mal neu starten da geht plus notebook billiger
drinne so also der hacker man so stehen geblieben wie dieser hacker das internet gerettet hat
ok über was könnte das sein was war das noch mal für einer das sind nicht die typen
die diesen bei diesem verschlüsselungsdroh ja ne wobei das war die typen gucken wir einfach
mal eine beste ok jetzt ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben leicht leicht übertrieben
noch das war das verschlüsselungsding war das nicht war das nicht die geschichte wo
dann wo irgendein typ ich weiß nicht ob es one cry war wo irgendein typ die hacker angeschrieben
hat oder was ist die hacker die die typen für die wo man die irgendwie erreichen konnte
irgendwie angeschrieben hat und gemeint hat irgendwie ihr habt meine ganzen privaten
fotos und ich kann ich hab das geld nicht krieg ich wieder zugriff und wo die leute
dann geantwortet haben ja ja hier ist dein key das auch etwas empathische hacker man
gibt aber die haben wahrscheinlich genug kassiert man solle 300 dollar in bitcoin zahlen um seine
hätte ihr wisst ihr was 2017 2017 300 dollar in bitcoins wisst ihr wie viel das heute
werdet ich auch nicht aber ich würde sagen wahrscheinlich so 15k oder so das ist ja übelst
explodiert die letzten drei zu bekommen der wurm verursacht drei bis sechs milliarden
euro schaden quasi innerhalb eines einzigen nachmittags und das wäre wahrscheinlich erst
der anfang gewesen doch ein schlagsiger schüchterner typ eins natürlich im keller was sonst irgendwo
in einer britischen kleinstadt hält war warum im keller einem einzigen schachzug auf aus
versehen bis dahin war er anonym im internet unterwegs und fast niemand wusste wer er war
jetzt wird er über nacht zum helden dies ist die geschichte eines brillanten hackers das ist ja
mal richtig old school alter ioc
hackers eines kolossalen triumf also die heckermans die heckermans die mögen noch
ioc das nordkoreanische militär und eines tage andauernden gefechts das war die geschichte
das war die geschichte der die die die control domain registriert hat oder gigantisch jetzt
wo stripes das grad schreibt das das war doch das war das war das nicht da wo die domain
registriert wurde wo die ganzen bots versucht haben ihren control server zu erreichen es ist
auch die geschichte einer dunklen drogen gefüllten vergangenheit jetzt übertreibt das aber wieder
üble banking malware steht dies ist die geschichte von marcus hutchins das heckermann intro alter
bevor es losgeht kurz zwei große shoutouts zum einen an das team von tomorrow anlockt sie lassen
uns für dieses video teile ihres materials danke und zum anderen an diese großartige
wired cover von andy greenberg sie bietet einen wirklich toll ist ich sage das heißt
wie red ein blick in die weil man die seite liest geschichte und youtube heißt ja auch nicht
youtube sondern you to be eigentlich so we just gonna okay pence champions ich weiß im frühling
2017 ist marcus hutchins 22 jahre alt er wohnt noch zu hause bei seinen eltern in elfre kuhn von dort
arbeitet er als botnet weiter weil es wären drei millionen was 2015 für 300 dollar bitcoins
wären jetzt drei millionen das kann nicht sein da müsste das seit 2000 das ist zwar krass gestiegen
aber das ist doch keine irgendwie 100.000 prozent gestiegen forscher bei cryptos logic einer
entsprechenden cyber security firma botnetz sind im prinzip netzwerb was ist da gelaufen
hutchins 22 jahre alt er wohnt genau nicht 300 bitcoins bitcoins für 300 euro für 300 euro
im jahr 2017 noch zu hause bei sein ja das ist hollywood was da läuft wo wir gerade dabei sind
ich muss auch mal kurz hacker modus aktivieren war immer immer wenn ich das sehe in dem video
weil es cooler aussieht muss ich auch den hacker modus anmachen sekunde sekunde für die richtige
hacker meiner atmosphäre auf vm starte erst mal den kram hier zumachen alles zumachen jawoll
jetzt ist gut jetzt leute merkt ihr es auch dass ihr so richtig im hacker modus seid wenn das
wenn das läuft ihr müsst ihr müsst jetzt quasi eigentlich linux kernel module in c programmieren
das ist so kommt so automatisch aus den fingern raus aber natürlich in dieser geschwindigkeit nicht
irgendwie einfach mit nicht normal und nachdenken ja richtige heckermans kacken quasi linux kernel
module direkt aus und nacheinander natürlich nur in holy c programmiert alles klar
genug heckermant wir machen das mal wieder aus und gehen wir wieder zurück zum video seinen
eltern in ilfre kuhn von dort arbeitet er als botnet forscher bei cryptos logic einer
entsprechenden cyber security firma botnetz sind im prinzip netzwerke aus gehackten computern
diese netzwerke kann ein hacker dann kontrollieren und koordinieren trifile solchen botnetz kann
man zum beispiel server angreifen oder massenweise spam verschicken hutchins ist wahnsinnig oder
corona verursachen darin diese netzwerke und ihre schad software zu infiltrieren und zu
kartografieren vielleicht ist er damals sogar einer der besten botnet forscher der welt er
hat außerdem einen relativ erfolgreichen blog in dem er über seine arbeit schreibt malware tech
gerade will er sich mal eine woche freinehmen als major so-called ransomware attack is underway
worldwide with more than 75.000 attacks reported a crippling cyber attack has businesses around
die arme news immer die sind so geil ich weiß ich ich gucke ja ich gucke ja manchmal so aus
just for fun so ein bisschen arme news die sind immer so voll aufgetan wie beschreibt man das am
besten so zu aufgehyped ich meine das hier jetzt so aufgehyped so so world on high alert genau es
ist alles es ist alles high alert extrem und nie dagewesen und dramatisch dramatisch trifft es
genau ja malicious software ok der tagesschau pence fast ein ja da stimmt right around the world wir
schreiben den zwölften mai es ist ein freitag wannacry zerlegt die infrastrukturen ganzer
unternehmen in london warum warum warum ist das so weil die sich gedacht haben es ist eine gute
idee windows file server zu verwenden oder was als windows file ja auch auch wenn aus falls aber
auch ein problem und was halt auch problematisch ist ist windows desktop clients aber gut da wirst
du nichts gegen machen können aber windows surfer ist so ziemlich das schlechteste was du machen
kannst für sowas matrix hd dankeschön für drei monate sam krankenhäuser lahm gelegt patienten
können nicht behandelt werden it mit arbeiter rennen durch die gänge um computern den stecker
zu ziehen bevor der wurm die maschinen bei der eine sache ich weiß ich weiß ich soll die videos
mehr durchgängig laufen lassen habt ihr recht aber was mir da wieder auffällt die it projekte
unsere regierung gehen ja auch öfters mal in die hose chat was ist eure einschätzung nach kommt
der europäische impfpass kommt das pünktlich wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben und meint ihr das
wird funktionieren und was taugen wannacry verbreitet sich unter anderem so schnell weil
er eternal blue nutzt das ist ein äußerst potentes hackenwerkzeug welches eigentlich von der nsa
entwickelt wurde wenige monate ihr seid ihr äußerst zuversichtlich vor war es geleakt
worden und stand ab da der ganzen welt zur verfügung microsoft hatte die entsprechende
schwachstelle in windows längst behoben aber leute und organisationen wer braucht patches
bei the way wo ich vor zwei jahren zu weihnachten rum mit meiner mutter in der notaufnahme war im
krankenhaus da lief ohne scheiß auf dem gerät noch wenn aus xp
das erste was ich gesehen habe bin aus xp booted da habe ich mir auch gerade auf fack
wo sind wir hier geladen erst mal bin aus xp gestartet nein das zeug ist ja nicht im internet
erreichbar das kann man machen aber es hat trotzdem ein bisschen ein bisschen doofen
nachgeschmack gehabt wo ich gesehen habe wo sie irgendwie das war so ein überwachungsgerät
wurde dann anschließt so wurde dann puls herzfrequenz alle möglichen sachen und das
bin aus xp erst mal gebootet updaten ihre software nun mal nicht und so infiziert
wannacry in kürzester zeit insgesamt rund 230.000 das kann durchaus was abbekommen weil das
hängt zwar nicht im internet aber irgendwie müssen diese bin aus xp dinger trotzdem zugänglich
sein ja du musst ja die irgendwelche settings drauf einstellen und so das passiert garantiert
zentral ja und wenn sich irgendeiner den scheiß eingefangen hat auf seinem admin rechner der
dahin kommt also so ohne ohne ist es auch nicht computer in 150 ländern zu den betroffenen
zählen unter anderem die deutsche bahn die spärbank in russland reno nissan honda telefonica
fedex boeing und zahlreiche weitere organisationen wie universitäten oder polizeistationen heute ist
man sich ziemlich sicher dass der angriff von nordkorea verübt wurde all das ist an diesem
freitagnachmittag noch ernsthaft wann das wirklich die nordkoreaner
dass sie sowas hinkriegen wirklich bekannt aber jeder sicherheitsforscher auf der welt weiß
dass wannacry wahnsinnig irgendwelche irgendwelche kekommers war es ist doch jetzt egal ob die russen
oder die nordkoreaner oder die chinesen kommen wir zu uns auf jeden fall ist hutchins bricht
seinen urlaub ab und schaut sich die malware an fast umgehend findet er etwas in dem die chinesen
website in der wurm ein system infiziert scheint er zu versuchen sich mit dieser website zu
verbinden hutchins merkt dass sie alle trivial allerdings gar nicht registriert ist seltsam ihm
ist klar dass diese domain nützlich sein könnte um das ausmaß des wurmes nachzuvollziehen also
registriert er sie kurzer hand für umgerechnet knapp 9 euro die nächsten stunden verbringt er
damit den gesamten datenverkehr zu analysieren der auf diese domain einprasselt aber tausende
von systemen versuchen auf die domain zuzugreifen sie alle wurden von wannacry infiziert so kriegt
hutchins einen überblick davon wie sich das virus global verbreitet und wen es erwischt hat dabei
ahnt er nicht dass er wannacry ein abrupt also eins ist schon mal sicher wir waren das mit wannacry
garantiert nicht das ist ausgeschlossen irf und so weiter punkt kommen ist ein kill switch ein
notaus schalter sobald der wurm in ein system eingedrungen ist schaut das programm als erstes
ist diese domain erreichbar wenn nein wird das system verschlüsselt und ab geht's wenn ja hört
wannacry einfach auf und bricht den angriff ab bis heute ist nicht ganz klar warum die programmierer
hinter dem wurm diesen kill switch eingebaut haben vielleicht um im notfall selber den stecker ziehen
zu können aber warum haben sie die domain dann nicht selbst registriert haben sie es einfach
vergessen wer weiß die gefahr war jedenfalls noch nicht gebannt die nachricht um die domain und den
blogger der sie registriert hat verbreitet sich wie ein lauffeuer in den nächsten tagen kämpfen
hutchins und sein arbeitgeber kriptos mit aller macht darum dass die domain online bleibt da wäre
natürlich der gewaltige datenverkehr der hunderttausenden von infizierten systemen
moment moment im hauptsache die domain ist registriert also ob da jetzt was von denen
drauf läuft dürfte doch erst mal egal sein das heißt es heißt irgendwas was eventuell
vielleicht um 200 antwortet oder so kontaktieren aber dann folgt ein massiver angriff eines der
brutalsten botnetz aller zeiten mirai die domain wird tagelang mit einer gewaltigen masse an
datenmüll bombardiert in der hoffnung die domain offline zu bringen warum die hacker hinter mirai
diesen angriff durchgeführt haben ist nicht schlussendlich vielleicht weil es geht ich
geklärt hat es muss man sowas nicht alles immer großartige logik haben seine kollegen bekommen
hilfe von amazon web services und später klaut flair um der attacke stammt ihr wisst ihr warum die das
gemacht haben nur für publicity das ist doch abs und klaut flair egal das ist rein dass ihr
name drinne steht sie umzuleiten nach mehreren tagen ist es endlich geschafft die domain bleibt
online und wannacry ist gestoppt marcus hutchins wird zum schüchternen helden der community aber
hier endet seine geschichte noch nicht ein paar monate später findet die defcon in las vegas
statt das ist die größte hacker konferenz schüchterner surfdude hutchins fliegt mit
ein paar kumpels hin lässt sich feiern und macht eine woche lang richtig heftig party exakt so sieht
ein schüchterner genauso eine woche heftig party machen in las vegas genauso sieht das als schüchterner
surfdude aus richtig heftig party seine entourage und er mieten ein monströses airbnb mit dem
größten privaten pool in vegas genau das machen auch schüchtern der surfdudes sie gehen zu open
bar event natürlich natürlich genau das macht man als als schüchterner menschen ja klar dann
als hutchins verkatert im flughafen auf seinen rückflug wartet wird er vom fbi verhaftet und
verhört haben wir nicht haben wir nicht gesagt dass er das selbst war oder vermutet haben geht
es vielleicht um wannacry leider nein ganz und gar nicht marcus hutchins hat eine dunkle
vergangenheit er hatte bereits eine nahezu obsessive faszination für computer und hacking
oh nein hat es ihn deshalb schon früh in die dunklen ecken des internets verschlagen hutchins
hat seine jugend in zwielichtigen foren verbracht selber botnetz gebaut illegale websites gehostet
und malware gekodet dabei war er schon immer ziemlich talentiert als er 16 war ist er deshalb
den falschen leuten aufgefallen und hat begonnen für sie zu arbeiten im alter von 19 jahren hat
marcus hutchins was das für ein bild im hintergrund aller wirklich große teile des banking trojaners
kronos programmiert also das ist kronos jetzt habe ich es kapiert war kronos nicht der da seine
kinder gefressen hat bei den griechen oder bei den römern kronos hat seine kinder gefressen und
irgendwann hat die haben die kinder ihnen platt gemacht damit konnten hacker sich heimlich über
längere zeit in systemen von nutzern ein ich weiß jetzt aber nicht mehr ich weiß jetzt aber
nicht mehr wie die kinder ich glaube die mutter die mutter hat ein kind vor ihm versteckt ich
weiß exquisite cool story griechische mythologie ja ich glaube die mutter hat ein kind vor kronos
versteckt und das ist dann groß und stark geworden und hat kronos den bauch aufgeschnitten alle
anderen kinder waren wieder raus ja oder es war gratos aus god of war kann natürlich auch sein
sie zum beispiel passwörter klauen wenn nutzer sich bei ihrem online banking anmeldeten kronos
konnte sogar gefälschte web formulare in websites einschleusen um leute das ist was ok sus wie es
die amis sagen sus in ihren pin code einzutippen so's während dieser zeit ist der schlaxige junge
aus england amphetamin abhängig geworden nach seinen aussagen hätten die schuldgefühle und
drogen schwere angstzustände in ihm ausgelöst er hat letztlich aufgehört schadsoftware für
kriminelle zu programmieren und einen kalten entzug gemacht 2017 lag dieses dunkle kapitel
seines lebens schon lange hinter ihm hutchins verbringt zwei jahre in den usa während er wegen
seiner beteiligung an kronos auf seinen prozess wartet in dieser zeit zieht er nach los angeles
als er 2019 verurteilt wird erwartet ihn eine überraschung der richter betrachtet ihn als
jemanden der schon vor langer zeit einen neuen besseren weg eingeschlagen hat und auch als
jemanden der die gesellschaft mit seinen fähigkeiten da freut er sich da hat er auch
recht da hat er auch recht sich zu freuen und sollte hutchins bekommt ein jahr auf bewährung
und ist frei
war so unfassbar zerstörerisch ein bisschen übertrieben hat eine video ja schon abschätzen
hat aber letztlich geht es in der geschichte des marcus hutchins auch um etwas anderes wie schnell
sich talent umfeld und überheblichkeit gerade in der welt des hackings zu einem destruktiven
cocktail vermischen kann er übertreiben vielleicht ist hutchins größte tat eigentlich aus eigener
kraft die kurve gekriegt und seine übertreibt so heftig Dinge gelenkt zu haben aus versehen eine
böse cyber bestie zu helfen ist da fast eher ein netter bunt ist das cyber bestie blies
das video war ja nicht schlecht und der typ ist sicherlich big brain aber das ist eine
gute frage ich also ich denke mir über folgendes also also bono checker sagt eine sache verstehe
ich nicht wenn er die webseite dem code fand dann muss er rausgelesen dass es kill switch ist oder
ich meine dass da sowas wie das da dann sowas wie zum beispiel wenn die webseite reichbar ist
kill ich ne das glaube ich nicht ich gehe mal davon aus das war glück und die webseite hat
herausgefunden nicht durch die code analyse von dem von dem bot sondern einfach in dem er traffic
mitgeschnitten hat er hat einfach sich eine kiste genommen wo war eine krei drauf war hat auf
irgendeinem netzwerk gerät in wireshark angeschmissen und hat geguckt was das ding für netzwerk traffic
verursacht und da siehst du relativ schnell wohin sich das ding connecten will ganz ohne
irgendwie code analyse oder sonst was und ihm war nicht klar wofür die domain also würde ich das
jetzt eigentlich schon interpretiert ihm war nicht klar was die domain macht er hat die sich einfach
mal registriert und dadurch dass er die domain hatte konnte er natürlich dann hatte tp so also
ein webserver drauf laufen lassen und einfach gucken was reinkommt
der hatte glück dass die hacker mans das ein bisschen verkackt haben weil die hacker
mans hätten das auch mit zertifikat machen können dann wäre das nicht möglich gewesen
amazon fulfillment center tour jetzt zeige ich mal ja
ja da habe ich mich schon gewundert und ein teil davon ist definitiv unterbezahlte subunternehmer
von subunternehmer das subunternehmer aber letztendlich solange das zeug pünktlich ankommt
kann ich dazu plus sagen hauptsache es kommt an
it's done with a symphony of machine learning automation and our amazing associates join us
as we see that amazing associates ja so lange sie nicht zu viel geld kosten in action in
an amazon fulfillment center welcome to an amazon robotics übrigens da war ich ja noch drauf
da war ich ja noch drauf dass die amazon thron am start sind ja mal zum thron für mich persönlich
kann es ja nicht schnell genug gehen dass amazon thron pakete austragen das fände ich so geil du
bestellst was was in bad hersfeld oder sonst wo in der nähe irgendwo im wahren lager ist und
innerhalb von drei stunden macht dann du musst dann wahrscheinlich einen landeplatz oder so
irgendwo im garten oder im hof oder sonst wie bereit stellen dafür die lassen sich da sicherlich
irgendwas einfallen ich fände das geil amazon thron huge fulfillment center this fc is one of more than 50 worldwide
where robots work alongside our amazing employees let's go inside at amazon we're customer obsessed
we're also obsessed with the safety of our employees in april of 2020 amazon began enhancing its
temperature screening process um corona zu erkennen oder was implementing thermal camera systems
throughout multiple business lines in north amerika now that our temperature is not detected as high
we're free to continue the tour by the way das haben die nicht das haben die nicht gemacht um die
mitarbeiter zu schützen das haben die gemacht dass ihr produktions und versand ding nicht zum
erliegen kommt man muss sich mal davon lösen dass sie das irgendwie machen würde zum wohle der
menschheit das machen die zum wohle für sprungs today we're going to follow the path of products from
where they're received stowed then picked packed and put on a truck for distribution the inbound
process starts with forecasting and ordering before anything arrives to the fc powered by
aws forecasting engine is used for over 400 million products daily let's go to the receiving
area as you'll see we put a lot of energy into our logistics it's a symphony of people aws
software and other high tech as kratzer werbefelder the result is a coordination between our great
employees and the finely honed computer systems we've evolved for more than 20 years our employees
are the heart and soul of our operation some are military veterans some are active members of the
community some are employees that work here with their loved ones they're all amazing das
typische werbeaussage wieder trailers full of vendor and small and medium business seller items
arrive at these bay doors by appointment employees unload the trailers and begin the process of
staging items located at their receiving workstations if this fc carries millions of items of inventory
and using the service known as amazon aurora we manage our inventory transactions and other
relational database needs at this station you can see how our inbound associate receives a product
and how those products are stowed in our inventory amazon one has to be real so logistics
can really drive you can certainly get excited about a few things at amazon but the basic thing
what amazon makes so successful is that the shit works otherwise amazon would never have been so
successful the shit just works and they are also in the framework of relatively tolerant with
sending back and giving back and other things so amazon is extremely interested in that the
people are satisfied so the customers not the employees, let alone the logistics or
delivery people would never have been so successful at amazon the shit just works
at other stores you always have to look at shipping costs shipping costs to your product value price
how is that different shipping service providers delivery time otherwise at amazon you look at
making a hook at prime up throw something in the goods basket and order and you know it's
not expensive and it comes within the next one two three days activated when an associate logs
into their workstation to perform their task storage pods arrive facing the correct side to
stow items into inventory every time an associate touches a product they scan a unique barcode for
that item which we call the amazon standard identification number or asin ah therefore
steht das das steht nämlich das kriegst du auch über die amazon api raus snake cs dankeschön
oder snj cs dankeschön für stufe 1 subscription that stored in our inventory system so we know
what the quantity and location of that item is any given time to manage our inventory history
we use amazon neptune a fast reliable fully managed graph database service from aws now
das ist das ist ein werbevideo für amazon und für amazon also und für aws we organize this in a way
where similar items are stowed together for example all electronics would be stored in the same
section however at amazon we found that it's more efficient to stow products using a randomized
method that's why by the way kriegt ihr auch mittlerweile fast alle liefungen von amazon nur
noch über amazon logistics und kaum noch über dpd dhl ups und wirft amazon logistics bei euch
auch die sachen manchmal über den zauen oder steckt es irgendwo rein ohne unterschrift ich
habe mir da gedanken ich habe mir ich habe mir gedanken dazu gemacht und zwar nee also
also bei mir ist es so wenn amazon logistics das ganze liefert die wollen keine unterschrift
und ich glaube das liegt daran amazon hat das ganze analysiert und hat festgestellt dass es billiger
ist keine unterschriften zu machen und die sache irgendwie zuzustellen als jedes mal eine
unterschrift zu fordern und die sachen aufzubewahren und die nehmen quasi diese fünf prozent oder wie
viel das ist was verloren geht oder reklamiert wird weil es kaputt gegangen ist oder sonst was das
nehmen die in kauf und die sagen die fünf prozent der sachen die die oder was weiß ich vielleicht
ist es sogar weniger ich sage jetzt einfach die fünf prozent der fälle wo es durch nicht richtig
abgegeben und unterschrift nee die wollten auch nein nein nein amazon wollte auch vor corona schon
keine unterschrift und die sind bestimmt zu dem schluss gekommen dass das einfach billiger ist
diese zeremonie nicht zu machen
um als das von jedem zu fordern also die paar die sachen die reklamiert werden sind billiger
als das was es kosten würde das immer ganz ordentlich zu machen bei mir unterschreibt der
briefkasten öfters ja ja das steht bei mir auch da das steht das steht unterschrieben von
briefkasten steht manchmal bei mir bei amazon entgegengenommen von briefkasten unter unterschrift
von briefkasten ja hey das ist big brain hey das ist das
ist clever das ist echt clever und wisst ihr warum das noch leute sind wisst ihr warum das
noch leute sind die das da einsortieren weil es billiger ist als maschine dafür zu bauen
das aber eine coole logik
natürlich von aws was sonst
auch liegt leute liegt
das ist ja geil das ist ja geil
das ist egal was hat der typ der da hinten am am am am hals hängen
erstmal custom software flaschen das ist aber cool also logistik sachen haben die
schon echt drauf so was zu bauen ist das eine ja so was bauen können sicherlich viele dass
das das das schwierig ist dass das so zuverlässig funktioniert dass es mehr arbeit abnimmt als
verursacht das ist das schwierige daran scheint ja gut zu funktionieren ob dhl sowas
auch hat ich glaube nicht in dieser in dieser ausprägung aber sicherlich was in die richtung
also ich denke bei dhl hat auch mehr als man sich vorstellt man denkt ja bei dhl gibt es
einfach nur fließbänder und leute die dran stehen die werden das sicherlich auch schon
deutlich deutlich moderner haben mittlerweile aber wahrscheinlich nicht in diesem in diesem
ausmaß zumal dhl ja auch keine wahren karte klassifizieren muss sondern nur pakete hat
der
und er erkennt, dass das Item dort gesetzt wurde.
Wenn das System erkennt, dass das Toten voll ist,
flascht die Lichter und der Bewerber
drückt den vollen Toten zurück in eine Serie von Konveiwörtern
und verwendet ihn mit einem neuen,
der automatisch in ihre Station gebracht wurde.
An dieser Stelle werden Bewerber
für verschiedene Kunden und Verkäufer gekauft.
Ich habe gesagt, ich stelle mir es halt ein bisschen doof vor,
quasi die lebendige Sortiermaschine zu sein
und das den ganzen Tag machen zu müssen,
aber von der Technik her ist es schon echt nice.
Kann ja einer ein Factorio nachbauen.
Ja, aber es ist immer noch besser, als wenn die Leute
hier durchs Warenhaus laufen müssten und das alles einpacken.
Aha, das leuchtet bestimmt auch auf.
Cool, das ist echt geil.
Ja, die Größe der Boxen ist bei Amazon
teilweise wirklich ein bisschen fail.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ähm, ich habe auch teilweise Dinger, die sind riesengroß.
Da drin liegen dann zwei USB-Kabel mit Füllmaterial.
Aber, aber es ist, da wie bei allem,
wahrscheinlich ist es billiger bei Amazon.
Es geht schneller, anstatt mehr Zeit darauf zu verwenden,
die richtige Größe zu finden.
Ja, ja, genau.
Ah, ja.
Krasse Scheiße, was?
Alter, guck mal, was das für ein riesen Ding ist.
Guck mal, was für ein riesen Teil, Alter.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal alles.
Das geht wahrscheinlich irgendwie gefühlt auf 50 Kilometer,
das war übertrieben jetzt, aber noch 100 Meter weiter.
Warum muss das über AWS-Lambda-Functions laufen,
um das...
Na, aber gut, weil es Amazon ist.
Das ist Surferless-Fliesband-Wartungsarbeit.
Ah, yes.
Das ist cool.
Das ist echt ein gutes Video gewesen.
Ich meine, letztendlich ist es natürlich ein komplettes Werbevideo für Amazon,
aber das zu sehen ist schon geil, oder?
Also, das haben die schon drauf.
Das muss man ihnen lassen, das haben die wirklich drauf.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen, mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde,
da muss ich sagen, da haben sie etwas übertrieben.
Das war irgendwie sowas wie NASA, 1000 Jahre, Technologie oder so?
Da haben sie...
Das da?
Ja, das da.
Vielleicht, das kommen wir später an.
Das Video ist eigentlich ganz cool,
aber die haben maßlos übertrieben.
Die haben uns erzählt, die erzählen zum Beispiel, dass wir 2024 eine Mondbasis haben.
Also, ich weiß, die wollen eine Mondbasis bauen,
aber 2024 ist, glaube ich, der aktuellen Roadmap nach
der abschließende Test für ihre Rakete, mit der sie Sachen zur Mond bringen wollen.
Aber das Video ist cool gemacht, aber trotzdem, die haben es voll übertrieben.
Die haben es echt voll übertrieben.
Oder wenn sie dann anfangen mit genetisch 2034 genetisch manipulierte Superastronauten
und sowas.
Ja, das werden wir bis 2034 auch nicht sehen.
2034, das sind 13 Jahre, das glaube ich.
Wenn wir Glück haben, haben wir flächendeckend 5G und ordentliches Internet bis dahin in
Deutschland.
Das Video ohne Bild, wenn ich mir das nicht angucke, BioWare größte Niederlage, Anthem.
Hoffentlich macht Maurice das Video, weil ich finde es immer so geil, wenn er in den
Videospielen sagt, zu Anthem, das ist der Bob Dylan der Videospiele, was die ja in
irgendeinem Marketingmaterial behauptet haben, da muss ich immer cacken, wenn ich das höre.
Es sollte der Bob Dylan der Videospiele sein.
So geil, jetzt fängt es auch noch damit an, Alter.
Leute, ich schwöre euch, ich habe vorher nicht geguckt, das Video.
Das ist aber nicht Maurice, der das erzählt.
Eingestellt, ja, Anthem war so ein typisches Ding, ne?
Das sah cool aus, aber es war komplett unzusammenhängender Müll zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie es angekündigt
haben noch.
Sie haben ja gesagt, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie es angekündigt haben, wussten sie
noch nicht mal, wie das Spiel aussehen soll.
Als großer Mass Effect Fan habe ich mich wahnsinnig auf Anthem als Next-Gen-BioWare-Spiel
gefreut und bin vielleicht auch deshalb so maßlos von seinem unrühmlichen Ende enttäuscht.
In diesem Video hier zeige ich euch jetzt aber die vier Kapitel, die Ankündigung, wo
sie selbst keine Ahnung hatten, was sie überhaupt produzieren sollen.
Dann Release ohne wirklichen Content, dann haben sie gesagt, es gibt neuen Content und
Anthem 2.0 und sie haben sich an keinen Zeitplan gehalten und jetzt haben sie es eingestellt.
Würde ich sagen, das sind so die vier Phasen.
Bestes, bestes, bestes Game immer noch.
Half-Life ist immer noch eines meiner absoluten Lieblingsgames, aber wahrscheinlich weil
es das erste Game dieser Art war, was ich gespielt habe.
Hatte, hatte jemand, ich habe Anthem nie gespielt, ne?
Hatte das wenigstens einen halbwegs sinnvollen Singleplayer mit einer halbwegs sinnvollen
Story wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Obwohl die Welt Anthem erst zur E3 2017 erstmals zu sehen bekommen hat, ist das Spiel zu dieser
Zeit bereits seit gut fünf Jahren in Entwicklung.
Wobei das Spiel dabei nicht wirklich stimmt und ursprünglich sollte Project Dillon was
ganz anderes werden als das, was letztlich als Anthem erschienen ist.
2012, nach der Veröffentlichung von Mass Effect 3, will das Team von BioWare-Adminton
um Game Director Casey Hudson nämlich etwas radikal anderes als ihre bisherigen Spiele
Mass Effect und Dragon Age machen.
Und dabei steht eine Idee im Zentrum, mit Freunden gemeinsam spannende und einzigartige
Geschichten erleben.
Statt wie bisher BioWare-typisch ein Rollenspiel zu machen, experimentiert das Team deshalb
zunächst mit dem Genre der Survival-Action, wo sich einfach aus dem Gameplay heraus Geschichten
ergeben können, sogenanntes emergentes Storytelling.
Oh, exzellent!
Das muss ich mir merken, das ist ein gutes Wort.
Emergentes Storytelling.
Ah, yes.
Das heißt, wenn ich den Stream anmache und einfach drauf loslabere, ohne dass ich es
vorher geplant habe, ist das dann auch emergentes Storytelling?
Ein galaktisches Bermuda-Dreieck funktioniert, sollen Spieler mit Freunden auf Expeditionen
durch gestrandete Raumschiffe und Alien-Ruinen gehen.
Dort wimmelt es außerdem von gefährlichen außerirdischen Wesen, es gibt extreme und
dynamisch wechselnde Wetterbedingungen und den einzigen Schutz bietet ein Roboter-Anzug,
der sogenannte EXO, also der Vorläufer des Javelins.
Die größte Inspiration ist dabei Superheld Iron Man.
Im Gespräch mit dem Magazin Kotaku beschreiben ehemalige Entwickler die Stimmung des Spiels
als einen Mix aus Dark Souls, Darkest Dungeon und sogar Shadow of the Colossus.
Super Game.
Geht nicht lang, aber Super Game.
Weil sich die Spieler mittels Greifhaken auch an riesige Alien-Monster festhaken können.
Mit, mit, mit.
Ey, Shadow of the Colossus hat ein Soundtrackstück, der ist mir bis heute in Erinnerung geblieben.
Super Soundtrack, warte mal.
Äh, das da, ich weiß sogar noch wie das heißt.
Also wer es noch nicht gespielt hat, solltet ihr unbedingt mal gespielt haben, echt geiles
Game.
Ja, also mega, mega Game.
Ok, Sebaro.
Wo gibt es, wo gibt es Mädels, wo gibt es auf Twitch Mädels im, äh, Wirlpool, zeig
her.
Meint Sebaro, das muss ich jetzt.
Changing into cute bikini, WTF, 15.000 Zuschauer, ok, na warum nicht, kann man ja machen, ne.
Warum, ok, ok, ok, Moment, Moment, Leute, ich lass euch da auch dran teilhaben.
Ok, man, man sieht, man sieht nichts, aber, aber, warum hat das 15.000 Zuschauer, ok,
ich weiß, das ist eigentlich keine, das ist eigentlich keine ernst gemeinte Frage, mir
ist klar warum das 15.000 Zuschauer hat, aber, so ganz wahr haben will ich immer noch nicht,
ja.
WTF.
Ok, was passiert da jetzt?
Nix.
Ok, wir müssen mal kurz in die Videos wollen, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, was da so abgeht.
Ok, ach du, ich, ok, ok, ok, ich weiß, ich weiß Bescheid, alles klar, alles klar.
Ok, VODs gibt's anscheinend auch nicht, ich würd euch sagen, Leute, Leute, wenn ich heute
nochmal 18 wäre, ich würde mich als Frau internifizieren und Boobcam Streams machen,
so sieht's aus, easy, easy money, easy.
Im Kern steht dabei das Durchhalten in einer lebensfeindlichen Umgebung etwa wenn die Spieler
die Mission bekommen den Grund für einen Vulkanausbruch herauszufinden, dann brechen
sie mit ihrem Exo und vorräten auf sehr sicheren Basis auf, hast du wohl die entsprechende
Oberweite, das ist ja heutzutage überhaupt kein Problem, also die richtige Oberweite
sich machen lassen ist ja quasi Investition in die Zukunft, sollen jetzt versuchen sich
möglichst lange durchzuschlagen, mit in der Wildnis des Planeten erbeutete Material soll
man sich seinen Exo Suit übrigens Stück für Stück verbessern können, statt dem Hochglanz
Hightech des fertigen Anthem sollten die Exos im ursprünglichen Design deutlich mehr zusammengeschustert
aussehen und nicht standardmäßig fliegen können.
Das sieht fast aus wie ein 1-2-1-0-Mess-Effekt Zu vielen dieser Ideen gab's kleine Prototypen,
ein wirklich zusammenhängendes Spiel dieser Version, ja gut, zusammenhängendes Spiel
gab's ja nicht mal bis zur E3 Demo von Anthem, bevor es nämlich dazu kommen kann, verliert
Project Dylan seinen Projektleiter, denn Casey Hudson verlässt im August 2014 nicht nur
das BioWare-Adminton-Team um Dylan, sondern BioWare komplett, sagt aber bei seinem Weggang,
dass er das Projekt auf einem guten Weg sieht, denn der Kern der Marke sei inzwischen fertig
gestellt.
Tja, der hat nichts, das die Rechnung gemacht mit den Stonksleuten von EA, was ist jetzt
zurück, ok, ok, ich muss doch mal gucken, wenn sie jetzt im Pool ist, zeig her, ach
du große, what the, what is happening, die muss aufpassen, gleich, gleich rutscht hier
der Nippel raus, Twitch, come on bro, egal, oh man, hat die Onlyfans, die hat bestimmt
Onlyfans, sie haben alle Onlyfans, Patreon, Onlyfans, Snapchat, alles bestimmt.
Beyond soll diese neue Marke heißen, der Name beschreibt dabei den Kerngedanken des Gameplays,
man zieht hinaus jenseits der Mauer der Heimatbasis, um die gefährliche Wildnis zu erkunden.
Ohne Casey Hudson tut sich das Team unter dem neuen Game Director John Warner aber schwer,
zwar ist die Moral im Team überdurchschnittlich hoch, ohne Hudson's Fokus, der Typ, der sieht
von der Seite ein bisschen aus wie der Bauer, oder, so auch in Bewegung, also nicht der,
nicht der, der, das sieht original aus wie der Bauer, ne, im Team überdurchschnittlich
hoch, ohne Hudson's Fokus häufen sich aber schon bald die Probleme, gleich mehrmals
baut das Team zum Beispiel die Flugmechanik ins Spiel ein, nur um sie dann wieder raus
zu schmeißen, weil sie so keinen Spaß macht.
Infolgedessen werden auch mehrmals weite Teile des Leveldesigns über den Haufen geworfen,
weil die Spielwelt ja auch zur Art der Fortbewegung passen muss.
Auch bei der Story kommt BioWare-Adminton nicht wirklich voran und holt sich deshalb 2015
Hilfe beim Dragon Age Autor David Gaider.
Wenig überraschend ist dessen Story-Entwurf aber wieder näher an dem dran, was BioWare
zuvor schon mit Dragon Age und Mass Effect abgeliefert hat.
Auch das führt zu mehr Arbeit für Artists und Leveldesigner, die die Story-Änderungen
erst umsetzen.
Alter, was ein Durcheinander, es wird ja noch schlimmer.
Als Gaider dann aber Anfang 2016 BioWare wieder verlässt, entschließt man sich seines
Spiels, die springen alle ab, die denken, oh nein, ich will nicht, dass mein Name da
dran steht, Story-Version komplett wieder zu verwerfen.
Aber auch die Spiel-Engine macht Probleme, denn Beyond soll wie damals alle EA-Spiele
auf der Frostbite-Engine entstehen.
Die hatte BioWare aber bereits bei Dragon Age Inquisition und Mass Effect Andromeda
mit fehlenden Features und schlechter Dokumentation Kopfzerbrechen bereitet.
Und auch für Beyond ist Frostbite fatal, denn viele der geplanten Survival- und Wetter-Features
kann BioWare nicht wie geplant umsetzen, deswegen man sie komplett strei-
Also das erste Mass Effect war auf jeden Fall Unreal, die anderen zwei wahrscheinlich dann
auch, keine Ahnung.
Und damit auch den Fokus des Spiels verändert.
Statt Survival schleichen sich so immer mehr Loot-Shooter-Elemente ins Spiel und das obwohl
die Studio-Leitung anfangs-
Als ich das das erste Mal gesehen habe, ich dachte, das soll ein Destiny-Klon werden,
oder?
Aber wenn ihr das so seht, habt ihr nicht auch als erstes gedacht, aha, wir machen
ein Destiny?
Fake?
Abklatsch?
Studio-Leitung anfangs den Mitarbeitern sogar verbietet, den erfolgreichen Genre-Vertreter
Destiny auch nur namentlich zu erwähnen.
Beyond sei schließlich kein Destiny-Klon und das wäre auch nicht die Art Spiel, die
BioWare machen will.
Wie schlecht es nach fast vier Jahren Entwicklung wirklich um Beyond steht, zeigt sich über
den Jahreswechsel 2016 auf 2017.
Wie auch in den Jahren zuvor soll nämlich ein Entwicklerteam-
Boah, da sitzen aber ganz schön viele auf einem Haufen, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist eher Spiele-Fabrik.
Wie auch in den Jahren zuvor soll nämlich ein Entwicklerteam eine spielbare Prototypendemo
allen anderen EA Studios für Feedback über die Feiertage zur Verfügung stellen und dieses
Jahr ist das Beyond-Team dran.
Anfang 2017 spielt diese Demo auch Patrick Söderlund, dem als Executive Vice-President
alle EA Studios weltweit unterstellt sind und sein Urteil ist vernichtend.
Er beschreibt den Zustand des Spiels als inakzeptabel und zieht die Notbremse.
Als Reaktion auf die Demo bestellt Söderlund führende BioWare-Mitarbeiter nach Stockholm
zur Krisensitzung bei den Frostbite-Entwicklern von DICE.
DICE stellt BioWare daraufhin ein Expertenteam zusammen, dass die Beyond-Entwickler dabei
unterstützen soll, eine ganz neue Demo zu erstellen.
Dafür bekommt man nur 6 Wochen Zeit.
Ja, das ist doch die typische Geschichte, Chef mag nicht, jetzt macht mal irgendwas,
was Chef mag.
Ob es was mit dem Produkt dazu zu tun hat, ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder zweitrangig.
Dafür bekommt man nur 6 Wochen Zeit.
Gegenüber dem Magazin Kotaku erklären anonyme BioWare-Mitarbeiter, dass sich dieses Projekt
wie ein Ultimatum anfühlt.
Entweder die Demo beeindruckt Söderlund oder Beyond ist gestorben.
Weil Söderlund vor allem die Flugmechanik gefällt, wird die wieder fest eingebaut.
Zudem legt man großen Wert auf hübsche Grafik, weil der Manager von diesem Aspekt bei der
letzten Demo am meisten enttäuscht war.
Nach 6 Wochen harter Arbeit zeigt man Söderlund die neue Demo inklusive fliegenden Exosuits
und der ist begeistert.
Im Prinzip haben die irgendwas gemacht, nicht was für das Game, sondern irgendwas um den
Chef gefällt.
Der anscheinend nicht in der Lage ist, irgendwelche gesamten Game-Konzepte zu erfassen.
Bildet dann auch die Grundlage dessen, was im Juni 2017 der Welt auf der E3 präsentiert
wird mit einer großen Änderung.
Denn EA informiert BioWare, dass es nicht möglich gewesen sei, sich die Markenrechte
an Beyond zu sichern.
Deshalb muss BioWare auf einen der Ersatz-Titel ausweichen und die haben ernsthaft das 3-4
Jahre entwickelt mit dem Namen und die sind nicht mal auf die Idee gekommen, sich das
im Vorfeld irgendwie hä?
BioWare nennt das Spiel ohne wirklichen Bezug um in Anthem.
Erst im Nachgang passen die Autoren die Story an und führen den Anthem of Creation, der
Ursprung, ein Lebens ins Narrativ ein.
Obwohl Engine, Gameplay und Story mit der heißen Nadel zusammengestrickt waren, schindet
BioWare mit der ersten öffentlichen Anthem-Demo auf der E3 2017 ziemlich Eindruck.
Fans und Fachpresse zeigen sich vom versprochenen Next-Gen-Gameplay begeistert und geben damit
wieder…
Ich mein, das macht auch echt was her, aber jetzt ist ja auch kein Wunder, warum das was
hermacht.
Im Prinzip hat man sich 6 Wochen lang mit Profis für die Optik hingesetzt und möglichst
beeindruckende linearen Kurzfilmen quasi gemacht, um es mal übertrieben zu sagen.
Doch für BioWare ist der E3 Triumph nur eine kurze Verschnaufpause.
Im August schließt EA nämlich die Niederlassung in Montreal, die kurz zuvor das hinter den
Erwartungen zurückgebliebene Mass Effect Andromeda veröffentlicht hat.
Der Druck auf Edmonton steigt dadurch immens, denn jetzt muss Anthem ein Erfolg werden.
Zu dieser Zeit hinkt Anthem zu seinem Entwicklungszeitplan bereits mehrere Monate hinterher, denn eigentlich
war ein Release bis Ende 2018 geplant, das Spiel aber immer noch in der Vorproduktion
zwar.
Andromeda war doch das, wo die Charaktere auch so komisch gelaufen sind, wo es so 50.000
Meme-Videos drüber gab, wo die so komisch gelaufen sind, als hätten sie in die Hose
gekackt oder die Kamera in die Gesichter geklitscht ist und die Gesichter nicht geladen wurden
und so Dinger.
Ordnung ins Chaos soll dann der ehemalige Kapitän bringen, denn im Oktober 2017 kehrt
Casey Hudson nicht nur...
Der ist erstmal wahrscheinlich vom Glauben abgefallen, was die aus dem Game gemacht haben
in den letzten drei Jahren, wo er weg war.
Als Projektleiter zu Anthem zurück, sondern wird auch neuer General Manager von BioWare.
Hudson zieht deshalb haufenweise Ressourcen vom nächsten Dragon Age ab und macht dessen
Producer Mark Darragh zum neuen Entscheider für Anthem.
Obwohl Anthem zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon seit über fünf Jahren in Entwicklung ist, entsteht
der Großteil des Spiels erst im letzten Jahr unter der Regie von Mark Darragh.
Dessen erklärtes Ziel ist simpel.
Wichtige Entscheidungen treffen, alle Termine von EA einhalten und das Spiel bis spätestens
Anfang 2019 fertigstellen.
Druck und Stress steigen bei BioWare enorm.
Vermehrt fühlen sich Mitarbeiter durch Monatelang...
Die müssen die ganz schön viel Kohle gegeben haben, dass der sich das wieder antut.
Das war bestimmt für den auch abzusehen, dass da nichts kralsbares rauskommt.
Die Leute sind so fertig, dass sie einfach mal weg sind und vielleicht mal wiederkommen
oder nicht.
Viele wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
Überstundenphasen, den sogenannten Crunch, ausgebrannt und kündigen aus gesundheitlichen
Gründen.
Laut mehreren befragten Entwicklern ist man sich dennoch im Studio sicher, so widrig die
Umstände auch sind, auf den letzten Metern wird es die BioWare-Magie schon richten, also
die Fähigkeit des Studios, alle Spielelemente auf der Zielgeraden zu einem spaßigen Gesamtwerk
zusammenzuführen.
Darragh hält zwar Wort, das was im Februar 2019 aber als Anthem erscheint, ist weit weg
von der Vision, die die Entwickler zu Beginn von Project Dylan hatten.
Das ist bei weitem nichts ungewöhnliches in der Branche, im Fall von Anthem macht sich
das Chaos in der Entwicklung aber bemerkbar.
Zwar sind Shooter und Flug-Gameplay spaßig, der Release ist aber nicht so gut, auch die
Story ist für BioWare Maßstäbe enttäuschend.
Der Typ ist doch 1 zu 1 aus Battlefield 4 importiert, oder?
Wait a minute.
Der Dude ist doch 1 zu 1 aus Battlefield 4 importiert.
Das sieht aus wie dieser Typ aus dem Singleplayer von Battlefield 4.
Zwar sind Shooter und Flug-Gameplay spaßig, der Release ist aber nicht so gut, auch die
Story ist für BioWare Maßstäbe enttäuschend.
Irish?
War das Irish?
Kann sein, ja.
Moment.
Battlefield 4 Irish.
Naja, nee, nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich, außer das beide schwarz sind, nee nicht wirklich,
die sehen doch anders aus.
Wann denkst du, dass das EJPT Zertifikat genug ist um einen Job zu, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das EJPT, was ist das EJPT Zertifikat, was zum, was, das hab ich noch nie gehört.
E-Learns Penetrate, ich hab keine Ahnung was das ist und was das taugt.
Sagt mir nix.
Der EJPT Zertifikat ist für BioWare aber noch nicht zu Ende, denn Anthem sollte ja
ein Live-Service-Game werden, also ein Spiel, das man über neue Inhalte immer wieder erweitert
und wenn jetzt zu wenig abwechselnde Inhalte und eine schwache Story die großen Kritikpunkte
des Spiels sind, dann kann man die doch im Nachhinein noch reparieren.
Tja, hätte man denken können.
Doch auch nach dem Release läuft's nicht nach Plan für Anthem.
Generell hat EA da so ein bisschen Probleme, ich mein guckt euch Battlefield 5 an, da wollten
sie auch im Nachhinein so viel machen und haben es nicht hingekriegt.
Und jetzt hast du einen Battlefield 5 ohne Normandie und alles.
BioWare ist mit Cataclysm nur einen, bevor man im Oktober auf ein Season-Modell umschwenkt.
Aber auch die Inhalte der ersten Season-Modelle sagt denen aus Cataclysm, eine Zweite...
Mir tun die Leute leid, die sich einen Season Pass für Anthem gekauft haben.
And in Wake ist auch ein geiles Game.
Statt Anthem weiter mit kleineren Updates zu versorgen, erkennt BioWare im Februar 2020,
dass man nochmal ganz tief ran muss an die Bausubstanz und kündigt deshalb an, Anthem
noch mal ganz grundlegend zu überarbeiten.
Als Anthem 2.0 oder Anthem Next soll das Spiel eine Art Reboot bekommen, der abwechslungsreiches
Gameplay und bessere Belohnungen bekommen soll.
Verantwortlich dafür wird ein kleines Team von rund 30 Entwicklerinnen und Entwicklern
unter der Szene von Twitch entdeckt.
Kleines Team von...
Okay, okay, für die Verhältnisse ist das 30 ein kleines Team, ja?
Aber...
Das ist für EA-Verhältnisse.
Aber wie beim Studio BioWare aussehen, sieht zuvor schon das MMO The Old Republic entwickelt
haben.
Mithilfe der Community kommt dieses kleine Team anfangs gut voran, schon bald wird es
aber still um das Projekt.
Als dann im Dezember 2020 schon wieder Casey Anzen und auch erstmals Mark Darragh BioWare
verlassen, soll Chris Daly Darraghs Projekt Dragon Age 4 übernehmen.
Was natürlich die Frage aufwirft, wer sich dann in Zukunft um Anthem 2.0 kümmern soll.
Eine Frage, die EA endgültig im Februar 2020 beantwortet...
Friends!
Okay, wenn das so schon anfängt...
Niemand.
Wie kommen die überhaupt die Idee darauf, dass die Leute ihre Freunde sind?
Frag die mal!
Ich glaube, die sehen das anders.
Bekannt gibt, wird Anthem Next eingestellt.
Die Anthem Server sollen zwar weiterhin online bleiben, neue Inhalte oder den erhofften Reboot
wird es aber nicht mehr geben.
Und das hat mich dann persönlich doch getroffen, weil ich vermutlich wie viele Fans da draußen
nach diesem ganzen Drama auf ein Happy End, also eine zweite Chance, wie bei Final Fantasy
Hearts und A Realm Reborn oder No Man's Sky gehofft habe, aber nix und wie schade das
um dieses Iron Man Flugballer Gameplay ist, weil das hat dir wirklich Spaß gemacht und
jetzt ist das einfach weg.
Vielleicht taucht es ja in irgendeiner...
Ja, die haben echt fast nur geile Games, die haben Half-Life stehen, die haben irgendeine
Half-Life Edition, keine Ahnung was das ist, sogar Half-Life 2, ich erkenne es jetzt nicht,
es ist auf jeden Fall das Half-Life 1, dann haben sie Max Payne 2, Alan Wake, auch beides
Poggers Games und der Rest steht ja sonst, äh, was ist das, Dragon Age 2, oah, Dragon
Age 2, hör mal bloß auf.
Die Portal-Dinger, aber die haben schon einen leisten Hintergrund.
In einer Form noch mal einen nächsten Mass Effect auf.
Aus dem Traum von Project Dillon hat Sir Bioware 9 Jahre später ein böses Erwachen gegeben.
In den letzten Jahren hat das Studio Dutzende erfahrene Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler verloren,
das Image bei den Fans ist angekratzt und das Vertrauen von Publisher...
Das ist nicht die Orange Box, das ist nicht die Orange Box, das ist normales Half-Life
1.
Packung.
...Arts in Bioware-Magie hat schwer gelitten.
Tatsächlich hat Anthem Bioware also nachhaltig verändert und sogar direkt Konsequenzen auf
das nächste Spiel.
Denn nach dem Niedergang von Anthem soll Bioware auf Anweisung von Electronic Arts bei Dragon
Age 2...
Achso, das rechte könnte die Orange Box sein, ja, da hast du recht.
...vier jegliche Online- oder Multiplayer-Features streichen und sich ganz und gar wie Singleplayer
konzentrieren.
Ich wünsche mir heute, ich hätte meine Half-Life-Packung und so gedünns aufgehoben, aber nope.
Wie sang schon Bob Dylan, the times, they are a changin'.
Das war sie also, die traurige Geschichte um das Ende von Anthem.
Aber schreibt mir doch mal in die Kommentare, wie geht's euch damit?
Seid ihr traurig darum, dass Anthem jetzt wirklich tot und begraben ist oder hat euch das von
Anfang an schon nicht interessiert?
Wenn ihr mehr zu Anthem wissen wollt, dann schaut unbedingt nochmal hier unser Testvideo
von damals.
Ne, das macht mich nicht traurig, dass Anthem weg ist, ich hab Anthem nie gespielt.
Okay, noch ein Gamster-Video gucken wir nicht.
Jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Hat jemand von euch diese, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich jetzt da drauf komm.
Kann mir jemand den Bob Dylan Vergleich erklären?
Ja, das Spiel hieß als Projektname Project Dylan und sie haben halt öfters auch gesagt
oder so Dinge angekündigt, wie das ist das Bob Dylan der Videospiele und sowas.
Die haben es halt selbst ein bisschen übertrieben.
Also genau, ich weiß jetzt echt nicht, wie ich drauf komme, aber hat jemand von euch
die South Park Folge geguckt mit den, wie hieß das, mit diesem Muskeltyp, der beim Frauensport
mitmacht?
Ey, das war echt, also das war eines der besten Folgen, die ich in letzter Zeit gesehen hab,
weil die so nah an der Realität dran war.
Da musste ich echt ein paar Mal kecken und das war halt wieder typisch South Park-mäßig
halt, mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn sich da wieder krass viele Leute drüber aufgeregt
hätten.
Weiß nicht, wie ich da drauf komme jetzt, hat eigentlich überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
I miss the Xbox Blade Dashboard, ne, das misse ich nicht.
Ja, das spielt bei mir nicht ab, nein, nicht das, das ist ja alt, ne, ne, irgendwas halbwegs
Neues, es gibt Menschen, die sich ernsthaft über South Park aufregen, ja, ja, ja, mit
Sicherheit.
Mehr als man denkt, was sagst du zu den Verfügbarkeiten der PS5, ich weiß gar nicht, ist die mittlerweile
verfügbar?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
So, ähm, oh nein, ich vermiss, ich vermiss, warte mal, zeigt er das irgendwo hier?
Ah, das, das Dashboard vermisse ich nicht von der Xbox, wisst ihr welches Dashboard
ich vermisse?
Bei der Dashboard, ähm, ich vermisse, nein, nein, das vermisse ich garantiert
auch nicht, weiß nicht, ob es zeigt.
Ich vermisse das, was nach diesem, was nach diesem, was nach diesem Dashboard kam, das
was die Xbox jahrelang hatte, so dieses, das, das normale, das ist in Anführungsstrichen
normale Xbox Dashboard, was besser ist als der ganze Crap, den sie aktuell bei der Xbox
und der, äh, ich weiß gar nicht wie die neue heißt, der, die wo man den Avatar und so
auch immer gesehen hat, nicht das, das auch, das da, das hier, das da, das hier, das da,
wo du dann auch die Avatare von dir und deiner Freundin, von Freunden angucken konntest.
Ja, oder das hier, das ist auch noch in Ordnung, aber das hier war beste, wobei ich glaube,
das sind die gleichen, bin nur mit dem Update und, äh, einfach, das ist nicht online eingeloggt,
das ist online eingeloggt.
Das fand ich top, das die, das, das fand ich, das war mein absolutes Lieblings-Dashboard,
besser als das auf jeden Fall, ähm, das war mein Lieblings-Xbox-Dashboard bisher, ja,
oder das hier, das ist ja alles das gleiche.
Die, die hatten echt ein cooles System, die hatten, die hatten ihre, die hatten ihre Xbox,
äh, ich weiß gar nicht, wie diese Avatar-Geschichte hieß und die hatten ihre Gamerscore-Punkte
und sowas.
Das war richtig cool, weil es damals so präsent war und du konntest ja damals auch mit Unlocks
in Games Items für deinen Avatar anlocken und so, eigentlich eine richtig coole Geschichte
und da gab's auch noch genug Leute, die so Gamescore-Hunting gemacht haben, quasi, die
haben sich, weiß ich, ob ich euch das mal gezeigt hab, es gibt so ein Avatar-Game, wo
du tausend, ähm, wo du tausend Gamerscores in fünf Minuten machen kannst, das war damals
so, das war übelstes Crap-Game, aber die Leute haben sich's halt gekauft beziehungsweise
ausgeliehen, weil du damit tausend Gamerscores machen konntest.
Sag ich's, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub, äh, über anhören was er sagt.
Ja, ja.
Moin, Niklas.
Man muss sich mal überlegen, die, ich lass' jetzt mal die Original-Xbox, die war ja
Xbox live arcade change the way we purchase games offering smaller bite-sized arcade experiences for cheap
Man muss nicht mal überlegen
Die ich lasse es mal die original xbox außen vor aber nehmen wir mal die xbox 360
Nehmen wir mal die xbox 360 aus 2008
Wie kann das sein dass eine xbox 360 aus 2008 ein viel besseres runderes online
Ein online implementierung plattform hat als nintendo in 2021
Wie ist das möglich das kann doch das kann das geht doch eigentlich gar außer man ist nintendo das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht möglich
Wie kann jemand 2008 was besseres bauen als jenemann 2019 in der richtung
Wie geht das überhaupt
Außer man ist halt nintendo nintendo schafft das aber das eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich
Eigentlich ein nintendo müsste eigentlich nur xbox live ein bisschen nachbauen
Und es wäre viel besser als das was sie jetzt haben
Teil für n asche ich meine ich meine
Die splatoon app was haben die sich dabei gedacht
Ich brauche ein smart fort und dann kann ich nicht mal matchmaking da drüben egal
60 games worth standard in widescreen mit htf gefühlt nichts aktuell
Offen virtual rewards für playing games ja bringe new life to games and expanding replayability
If you owned an xbox übrigens ich hatte nie den ich hatte nie eine kaputt xbox
You may remember this
Ja das kenne ich auch noch aber ich fand das danach besser
Die original xbox dashboard und selbst das ist besser als nintendo online
Was excellent it was simple clean provided an excellent user experience and most of all it was fast
Das stimmt. It's simply organized each of the main features of the console into separate sections and the term blades
Comes from the sections themselves
Aesthetically the concave blades follow the same design moment. Er hat keine hintergrundmusik. Ich muss mal ein bisschen hintergrundmusik machen
Die fat model in a viet die habe ich auch noch the blade stash das fett model companies aqua from san francisco
Which had previously worked with microsoft for eight years before the blades dash
design the xbox 360s dashboard and guide and they would test different prototypes with focus groups in five countries
Ich habe mich eigentlich gesagt nicht ja das das ist mein lieblings dashboard the blades dashboard would be replaced with the nxe or new
xbox experience
Was das für das war mein lieb das war mein lieblingsdashboard
since then
Hör mal auf so ach gott das ist so schlimm und the gone numerous dashboard updates with the metro style dash being the xbox
360s final form and this was the dashboard that would launch into the beginning of the xbox one era
But after many years of iterations of xbox 360 dashboards many people missed the blades dash
It was simple clean fast and effective. Ich fand das mittlere am besten later dashboards somehow became more sluggish
slower
advertising
Particularly so viel krepp so viel krepp ist in dem neuen dashboard drin du weißt du weißt teilweise gar nicht mehr wie was funktioniert
xbox live gold member
There was more focus a steampunk der sport ja
movies and music
If you just did steampunk beste
This was particularly frustrating as you would have to navigate the dashboard in order to get to the games tab and
Sadly, it's not possible to just go back to the blades dash
Ja, du kannst du kannst du kannst dich auch nicht nicht xbox live verbinden mehr mit dem alten
Das fanden die xbox 360 processor
After each firmware update it's simply not possible to go back to an earlier firmware
So the only real way to experience the blades dash is to find an xbox 360 out in the wild that hasn't been updated since
2008 ja mit der kannst du nicht online gehen is my one and only
xbox 360 stress test kit that has a early version of the kernel as you can see it's running
6723 now this is a
Firmware or flash that does have the that's a very old school now
Ob das noch eine ist die nicht mal hdmi hatte
Killer kit is a stress test. Ich finde die wert wahrscheinlich nicht viel für alte xbox 360 interessieren sich nicht so viele leute developers and qa
Would use in studios to basically just stress test the games and make sure that they would pass certain
requirements during the
certification process for the game to ultimately get certified and then go gold and then be sold in
technology in place it means that you can never go back so i've kept this
Windows mediasender haben sie das nicht auch mittlerweile eingestellt
Ich habe mir zwar ich habe mir so auch 2005 rum also den mediasender pc gebaut das lief naja
Da bin ich jetzt mit meinem schiel tv und kodi und so deutlich glücklicher
stock as possible
But what i'm going to do is connect up a 60 gigabyte hard drive and show you kind of the user experience that you were
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt nicht gucken das ist eigentlich ziemlich langweilig
Das ist der winnows media player. Das ist diese standard winnows media player
so fest
Damals damals hat man das im fullscreen gemacht und fand es richtig geil die grafischen effekte von mediasender
You know, listen to your playlist on your xbox 360 mediasender wurde zu kodi was nein quatsch das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar sachen
There was a really cool visualizer as you can see here that was developed by none other than jeff minter from llama soft
He was rama
Okay, moment wenn ich an lama denke
winnlama s
Excellent, das werde ich auch nicht vergessen
Aber an all das video von den minecrafts aber das ist das da wo der kabum mit dem langen lachs rumgelaufen ist
Winamp im browser geht zeit mal. Oh, das sieht tatsächlich übelsähnlich aus
Ja
Das sieht tatsächlich übelsähnlich aus
Ja, aber es ist halt einfach nur es ist gut gefakt ist css, oder
Wie hat er das gemacht
Ja
Ja, es ist im prinzip einfach nur gut gemacht das html css mit der optik nachgebaut
Aber zumindest zumindest cool dass es auch mit dem
Das ist übrigens kaputt kann man den visualizer noch desktop mode. Ah
Guck mal damals damals schon damals schon weep skins am start gewesen
Es gibt ein fucking jackie jackie chan skin
Ja, aber ich muss unbedingt den preisschirm neu starten das wieder funktioniert
So was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an wir gucken uns eine runde wir gucken uns wir können uns eine runde
Battlefield angucken ich muss jetzt eine runde bfw eine runde bfw 4 top plays oder oder wollen wir uns oder wollen wir uns mcdonalds versus hacker angucken
Komm wir gucken uns das zuerst an
Fast food chain in the world has stores all over the globe and they sell to billions of customers
But today we ignore 69 sachen geblockt instead take a look at the regular everyday folks who are using creative loopholes
the cheese mcdonalds
Profit was McDonalds muss ich immer dran denken es gab früher wo ich
Wo memes seiten und so noch nicht so angesagt waren also
Wo ich so in eurem alter war da gab es so ein ultra viral video das zu der zeit wurde
Asitoni auch in anfangen viral war wo einer seine mcdonalds bestellung gerappt hat
I want a double cheeseburger and a fucking chicken wrap und so
Jetzt habe ich irgendwie gemerkt das fand ich damals mega lustig heute gibt es wahrscheinlich 50 milliarden solcher videos in der richtung und die das
alle nachmachen
So so get yourself comfortable as we're going to be taking a look at all of the best times someone has exploited and cheated
McDonalds using their own systems against them and who better to talk you through these fantastic stories than the king of exploits and tea drinking
The spiffing brit that's right. It's me so ladies and gentlemen
It's time for today's stories to begin and of course we're going to be all versus a guard ich habe beides nicht laufen
Kann ich dir grad nichts zu sagen?
Start with a trip down to the land down under as we take a look at how some absolutely incredible
Aussies managed to completely destroy the economy of mcdonalds
By the way angeblich kann man mit der nordsee app
Unendliche viele brötchencodes generieren habe ich auch irgendwo gelesen
Aber nie ausprobiert
Es gibt sogar eine nordsee a nordsee api app
Auslese app geschichte auf github die irgendwie brötchencodes generiert
Now if there are two things in this world that I just absolutely love as a brit it's happy australian accents and stacking modifiers to create a negative value
Now way back in 2019
Some aussie mates went to a location locally referred to as mackers
They arrived with a huge hunger and desire for burgers and a vegetarian friend called harry naturally
They stroll up to one of these brand new fancy modern ordering computers
Now their friend harry wants ten one dollar hamburgers
Ich war ungelogen leute ich war glaube ich fünf jahren nicht mehr in mcdonalds
Harry is a vegetarian and can't eat meat if harry were to have any meat even so much as touch his lips
Even so much as touch his lips there's a very real chance that he might explode and destroy everything in a five mile radius
There is also the more likely chance that he will simply give the restaurant a bad review on trip advisor
So harry needs a burglar's hamburger well luckily mcdonalds is willing to cater burger king was auch fünf jahre nicht mehr
By allowing users to customize their orders the intention of this is of course to let users add more to their meals
Want an extra burger patty in that one dollar hamburger okay well that's gonna cost you one dollar and ten cents
McDonald's decided to charge this much to encourage you to buy a more expensive burger
Instead of just adding another burger patty to a single hamburger there was just one slight issue
By saying that the patty costs one dollar ten you've also just said that by removing the patty
The one dollar burger goes down one dollar and ten cents in cost meaning a burgerless hamburger breaks mcdonalds
And gets calculated to be worth minus ten cents
Moment das funktioniert mcdonalds would technically pay you to buy this product so not only have these
Aussies just found a way to solve world hunger with ketchup bread but they've also just found an infinite
Money machine provided you're fine with all of your money coming in the form of mcdonalds food now the
Aussies here use their newfound exploit to buy 10 burglar's burgers and consequently ended up creating a credit of a standing total of minus one dollar
Using this negative dollar they then spent it on a regular dollar hamburger this time actually containing meat
And this balanced out the total to an incredible zero dollars
All they had to do was press complete of course naturally no payment was taken as the order was just zero
And yet the machine still printed out a receipt and said no payment required
After a few minutes of a poor employee trying to make a hamburger without the element of a burger
The order was actually complete and given to the australians and would you look at that it's a free burger surrounded by ten ketchup-y bits of bread
Now these australians had just discovered something incredible and so naturally they shared this knowledge with the world now logically speaking
There is no limit to the amount of ketchup bread you can order so what would happen if you took this to its logical extreme
Well in order to get yourself a large big mac meal in australia you'd need eleven dollars
Okay, das heißt du musst jetzt erstmal irgendwie 60 60 brötchen ordern dass du dir das menü kaufen kannst
65 cents or in exploiters terms you could have all of this for free with just
117 ketchup-y buns now hats off to whoever can convince a mcdonald's restaurant to make 117 empty burgers for free
But there is genuinely a real chance that someone actually managed to do this in australia naturally shortly after the australians revealed this exploit mcdonald's pulled the classic corporate response
By saying everything was fine and security was excellent and after a few days they fixed this exploit in all of their ordering machines
But this is the power of stacking negative discounts to gain free items
It's a surprisingly common exploit online and heck it's even one that i've run into on many different websites
I think my personal favorite was using a loop of stacking discounts on amazon to gain infinite free gift cards
But hey, that's a story for another day as we have more mcdonald's stories to tell and trust me
We're about to dive into something very spicy ladies and gentlemen
You might need another cup of tea for this one because we're about to reveal the infinite cheeseburger loop exploit
Now mcdonald's is no stranger to giving away free food, but they always do so on their own terms
Well, allow me to introduce you to a random bloke from england who found a bug in the mcdonald's app that allowed him to steal from the rich and give free cheeseburgers to the poor
The man effectively became the cheeseburger jesus by converting a simple
The new foodie messiah is none other than jordan miller a 21 year old average british bloke now it all began with a very simple promotion event
mcdonald's wanted to celebrate the release of their brand new delivery app with a free gift for every new user who signed up
Very own free cheeseburger. What a fantastic way to welcome new users
Who doesn't like free food? I for one will do anything for food
Which is why today's video sponsor is gregg's
They they actually didn't pay me or give me anything mind you but they do make some incredibly cheap and tasty pastries
I'm just saying please give me money gregg's please please respond to my emails just anything
I need a sausage roll. So yes, if every new user gets a free cheeseburger
What could possibly go wrong?
Surely millions of people will sign up and enjoy all of these fantastic cheeseburgers
Ah, well it turns out there was a minor issue
You see the issue is when you have a simple line of code that determines what is and isn't a new user
It best be a perfectly balanced line. Also, das ist
eher
nicht der code für die mcdonald's app sondern irgendein arduino ding
würde ich mal sagen
It best be a perfectly balanced line of code with no exploits
Well, this line of code was no match for cheesus
The man very quickly discovered that it was very easy to dupe the algorithm behind the app into accepting just about any
Identity that was thrown at it
Now jordan was a dab hand with computers and knew that if the promotion was accurate and it was one free cheeseburger per person
Then all he needed to do for infinite cheeseburgers was to find a way to generate infinite people now
You see using a basic email alias set up and a few lines of code anyone can mass produce fake email accounts
For the app to detect then all you need to do is have another program skim all of the reward codes that get sent back to
The false emails and hey presto you have yourself 100 free cheeseburger codes. Okay, die haben den Fehler gemacht das als reward codes rauszugeben. Du müsstest das gebunden machen eben an die app installation
Dann könntest du das zwar auch machen aber da müsstest du mit 15 geräten bei mcdonald's ankommen
What did jordan do with his newfound discovery?
Well, he ordered so many cheeseburgers that he brought his local mcdonald's to a standstill
The manager of the branch even had to join in and assist in the sudden creation and fabrication of 100 suspiciously meaty cheeseburgers
So what did jordan do with his plentiful supply of cheeseburgers?
The man now had technically enough free food to give him the calories necessary to keep himself alive for almost an entire fortnight
But jordan was a selfless individual who immediately took to the streets handing out the burgers to random pedestrians homeless people and colleagues
Now of course following his escapade jordan vowed never to use his power again and reported on the issue to mcdonald's who naturally
Pretended the issue didn't exist and let the promotion end
But for a brief period of time thanks to the discovery of one man
It would have been possible for every mcdonald's in the uk to collapse following an infinite order of cheeseburgers
All it would take is about a team of five people and literally anyone could easily place an order for
100 000 free cheeseburgers in any mcdonald's restaurant consequently bringing it to a complete and utter standstill
This is the closest we've ever come to a cheeseburger-based apocalypse, but we've seen how the australians exploit mcdonald's
We've seen how the brits exploit mcdonald's. What about some super duper efficient germans?
Well, ladies and gentlemen get ready for the germans versus mcdonald's. Trust me. This is one you don't want to miss
The
Germans are famously a group of people who are fantastic at many things the exploiters behind this exploit are a few friends from hamburg
Who are coders by trade using their experience with coding and programming?
They were able to be in the perfect position for discovering this incredible exploit and unleashing
Unlimited power in the form of free mcdonald's food, of course
So lenny and david are two software developers located in northern germany their antics have made their names legendary as the hamburg hamburg
Das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen
Das haben wir dazu haben wir doch schon mal was gesehen. You see the pair discovered. Das kommt einem bekannt vor
There's often a link to a survey and of course if you do the survey you get yourself a coupon code for a free small drinks
That's right. Ladies and gentlemen, you can get a free cup of tea
We must secure the tea more tea tea tea tea tea
Sorry about that. What it's like when a spritz get a whiff of the leafy goodness
So mcdonald's in an effort to basically get more reviews on their products and restaurants created a system whereby fans of the fast food can
Review their meals and be given a reward
There's only one minor issue lenny and david noticed that the review websites code was structured in a way that meant the information
Das ist generieren kann ich da habe ich mal was zugeguckt was always the same
Meaning all lenny david had to do for unlimited drinks was create a program that just replicated the instruction and repeated it over and over again
Instantly david and lenny now had access to more suspiciously meaty milkshakes than they could ever possibly use
But this was just the tip of the proverbial glitched iceberg as mcdonald's had not set stock photos
Appetite for exploits they knew that if it was that easy to get the server to print out coupon codes they could probably
Find a way for it to print out any coupon code for any mcdonald's product
It took them five hours, and then david managed to crack the code you see mcdonald's used a linear coupon code system
We're basically if you can predict big brain mcdonald's
Alter then you can get the mcdonald's server to effectively print as many coupon codes as you like for whatever food you like
So here's how the exploit works. Lenny and baby get peckish so they load up a vpn on their laptop
And then they go on to the mcdonald's survey website
They then decide that of course they want some nuggets and they run the nugmaster.exe program
The mcdonald's server detects that someone has just completed a large quantity of non-existent surveys and needs to be rewarded
So it creates a brand new nugget coupon code and shoots the reward immediately back with no questions asked
So david and lenny then waltz into their local mcdonald's in hamburg and collected their 17 euros worth of free food
And with that the entire mcdonald's company collapsed under the financial pressure of giving away free food
It was so sad grimace even came out of retirement to announce the bankruptcy of mr
Ronald mcdonald and on today's video just one like equals one prayer for mcdonald's
Maybe if we can hit 50,000 likes we can save this billion dollar company from financial ruin
Okay, but here's what really happened david and lenny walked into the local branch to collect their food
And they actually felt so bad for getting the food for free
They even told the local manager of their exploits the manager naturally just said keep the food you earned it
And with that hamburgers waltzed out of the restaurant with their giant booty of free nuggets
Now the issue is david understood the risk of this power and knowledge that they just uncovered other people might soon discover this exploit
And when they do they might sell the coupon codes when it's so easy funktioniert hat und ich hätte dem manager sogar gesagt
Dann hätte ich da kein schlechtes gewissen da öfters mal einkaufen zu gehen
Da kann auch nicht mal im hinter da kann auch nicht mal später jemand kommen und sagen du hättest gegen irgendwas verstoßen
Weil ich meine du hast dem typ ja gesagt
In the wrong hands this free food exploit could easily be turned into an infinite money exploit in my hands it
Instantaneously would be turned into an infinite money exploit, but the gents of course decided to do something nice
They told McDonald's about the exploit and for many weeks McDonald's customer services did the classic thing that it always does and pretends that it doesn't exist
But after a while a reward was given to Dave and Lenny and the exploit was subtly fixed in the background
But remember ladies and gentlemen similar to video games every time there's a new update or an old bug
That's fixed in a system a new one is instantly created. This is the lore of exploits
And there we have it ladies and gentlemen all of my very favorite mcdonald's verse
exploiters scenarios whereas you can tell pretty much every time mcdonald's lost out
This is the power of exploiting a very simple system and my goodness is it just majestic
If you enjoyed learning about today's exploits and you want to see more like it then hey recommend a couple of companies down below
I'll be more than happy to actually reveal every single exploit that exists in all of these companies histories every single company has a
Million exploits that have happened in the past and are in fact still active. It's insane
And if you of course want to see more exploits as and when you reveal them be sure to subscribe and you can even turn on
Is ja nix for 20 viewers. Ja, das ist jetzt also das ist ja nicht das
Erste mal dass man irgendwelche gutscheindinger und so ausnutzen kann
Der link ist richtig gut, ja
Ja, wir müssen jetzt eine runde battlefield gucken. Wir gucken eine runde battlefield
Ich hab übelst hunger leute wie lange bin ich schon an
Okay, drei stunden machen ich hab übelst kohldampf ey
Ich hab übelst kohldampf ey
Okay, drei stunden machen ich hab übelst kohldampf ey, aber wir gucken eine runde battlefield muss jetzt sein
So sobald sobald er wieder anfängt mit irgendwelchen komischen flugzeug clips
Dann hab ich keinen bock mehr. Die letzten battlefield games waren nur flugzeug clips. Ich will Infanterie bash sehen
So war es da genau bam in your face und die gegner checken mal wieder nix
Boah hat der ein glück gehabt dass der gerade mit seinem kopf direkt in das hipfire gelaufen ist leute
Guckt euch das mal an
Hat der ein glück
Der ist ja voll mit dem gesicht in reingelaufen
Bam bam was was für eine shotgun ist denn das?
was zum
Ist das ist das die pistol pistol ersatz shotgun was ist das für eine shotgun?
Battlefield 6 skill based matchmaking ey ich sag's euch ich hab's jetzt aus pommas oder spaß gesagt ich kann's mir auch gut vorstellen
Oh nein, please hör auf mit chat gedürzt
Ich hab keine shotgun ich hab keine ahnung ich weiß gar nicht was das ist
Stopp ich will nicht mehr chat gameplay sehen
Das ist wieder irgendein leerer server wo sie drei stunden im kreis geflogen sind bis es funktioniert hat
Und skill und der letzte auf dragon valley ist einfach brillant
Insane chat clips insane huge massive insane chat clips
Ich will genau infanterie bash will ich sehen in your face
Ich hab ja schon wieder vergessen es gab ja einsatzschilder in battlefield 4
Warum ist warum ist die granate grad nicht unter seinem fuß explodiert hier wo ist die hin
Da liegt die granate warum kriegt er kein damage davon ah impact ah das kann sein
By the way battlefield 3 metro größer bf 4 metro
Die gegner sind ja mal wieder komplette no hands
Aber gut ist normal das normal
Sonst kriegst du ja so clips nicht hin ich darf mich ich darf mich da drüber nicht beschweren weil gegen so kack noobs spielt man eh am liebsten
Da reicht da reicht drei drei kopf nicht mal für
Da das müssen das eigentlich nur ein kopf die gegner
Der Typ labert immer das kleine
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen was das für eine map ist es ist nie mit dem motel was einstürzen kann ne
Ne oder
Ist das nie mit dem motel was einschürzen kann oder ist das dlc map
Ne das ist dlc map
Oder was ist das für ne map
Das dlc map
Schreckt so was guck ich gerne an
Max was zockst du zurzeit so näher in der mangelung ordentlicher spiele leider nicht allzu viel
Ja big mic hd dankeschön für den zapp
Um
So muss das sein, als weil es auch so ein unterschätztes Ding, das habe ich in Battlefield 3 auch erst
viel zu spät entdeckt, eine ultra nice Waffe und das ist nice, ok ich weiß nicht was mit
dem Chatpilot los ist, aber das zu treffen in Battlefield 4 ist tatsächlich nicht ohne,
das war in BC 2 mit dem AT4 deutlich besser, das ist tatsächlich so, gegen Noobs spielt
es sich immer noch am besten.
Ja die habe ich glaube ich insgesamt einmal gespielt oder so die Map, lege Hände gemacht,
Dani Lambert, neuen Dankeschön für den Zapp, Big Mike HD, exzellent Subscriptions, ach
das ist die M16, die hört sich ein bisschen anders an in dem Teil.
10 Kills in total, once again, on Propaganda, Rush, getting towards the MCOM and defusing
it, a brilliant objective play.
So mag ich das, ordentlich Gegner geschreckt, äh M416 meine ich ja, die hört sich ein
bisschen anders an als in Battlefield, Battlefield 3, die haben ja recht viel übernommen was
das angeht, aber das Model sieht auch mehr oder weniger aus als in Battlefield 3, aber
das Sound und die Schussgeschwindigkeit glaube ich ein bisschen anders, das sitzen sie drin.
Ja Hardline wurde schon komplett vergessen, das ist richtig, leider hat Venice Unleashed
keine Spiele, Moment wir gucken mal kurz, Hardline das Problem an Hardline war, dass
der Modus mit dem sie geworben haben, dieses Bankräuber Szenario, das hat halt gesagt.
Massive, viele Spieler, das ist echt kacke, weil es spielt sich viel besser als Vanilla,
aber die haben es halt auch, das ist das wenn gute Techniker ein Projekt machen, technisch
ist es wirklich nice, gut es tut sich gerade nicht viel, wahrscheinlich sind sie selbst
demotiviert, aber das war an vielen Stellen, hätten wir das anders machen müssen, wir
hätten offizielle Surfer bereitstellen müssen, 2-3, das ist der Typ der immer mit bitte
aktivieren sie Windows spielt, dass die Leute einfach so eine konstante Experience haben.
Erstmal Werbung machen, ich habe das Gefühl die Gegner sind in Battlefield 3 schneller
gestorben als in Battlefield 4 und du konntest nicht mehr so gut durch Leute durchschießen.
By the way ist euch mal aufgefallen, Battlefield 4 ist das einzige Game wo die Claimors realistisch
sind, nämlich mit dem Stolpertrat und nicht irgendwie per Laser oder so.
Sag mal, redet er immer leiser, ich meine sonst redet er auch, aber das verstehst du
ja kaum.
Du kannst 3000 Kilometer weit retzen in dem Spiel, jawoll, an der Treppe geht echt erstaunlich
viel, ich habe ja auch diesen Clip wo ich da irgendwie 20 Leute Kille oder so an der Treppe,
Alter was für eine Range, Bäm, boah ey, das ist, was für eine Range, meine Fresse guckt
euch das mal an, das ist eine fucking Shotgun, ja Slug Ammo, das fand ich damals auch schon
bescheuert, mein hallo das kannst du nicht sein, warum noch ne Sniper nehmen wenn man
das haben kann.
In Bad Company 2, was richtig krass war in Bad Company 2, Bad Company 2 in Slugs und
wenn man diese Auto Shotgun genommen hat, damit hast du ja auch One-Shotted across the map
wenn du gehitted hast.
Wo ist denn der fucking 1 in 1 Logo drauf, top, ist das Marcel Davis himself, recht Arbeit
in der bei 1&1, ich glaube nicht das 1&1 Random Battlefield Streams sponsort, gefühlt sind
diese Clips zu 90% locker, ist das das Lidl Wasser, das habe ich auch immer, das ist auf
jeden Fall ein Deutscher dann, warum hat er nen YouTube Link zu seiner Handcam, schrägt
in den Korb, Alter, gut gezielt, was ist das für ne komische Maus, sieht ein bisschen
aus wie diese Apple Maus, aber wirds nicht sein, ne das ist ne Logitech oder, G305,
ich kanns echt nicht richtig erkennen, es hat hinten auf jeden Fall ein Logo rausgucken,
also es könnte, ich weiß es nicht, G305, ok der Chat weiß Bescheid, G305, äh nein,
G305, könnte tatsächlich sein, ja, ok das nice, das nice, das musst du auch erstmal
treffen, Konsolen Battlefield 4, weiß ich nicht, es gibt ab und zu mal Clips von, aber
kann ich nicht so sagen, auf dem PC auf jeden Fall noch, nice, er sagt sogar noch weiter
einen Clip von Top Play, Infantry Bash Plays ist das beste in Battlefield, guckst mir viel
lieber an als irgendwelche Fahrzeugstelle, heute hört sich der Sprecher ja besonders
motiviert an, findet ihr nicht auch, deswegen ich hab den absichtlich ein bisschen leiser,
der eh immer das gleiche erzählt, oh, Smoke Spray, ja bei Chat Clips ist er immer gehyped,
das stimmt, das war aber nicer, Clip, er hat schon noch mal Infantry Bash gemacht, excellent,
Smoke Grenade und IR Side, ja, wobei geht das in Battlefield 4 nicht immer noch, dass
du durch Smoke gucken kannst mit dem IR, in Battlefield 3 gehts glaub nicht, oder was,
umgedreht in Battlefield 3 gehts, in Battlefield 4 gehts nicht, ah ich weiß es immer, Overwatch
auf Twitch hat gerade 17k, naja immerhin mehr als vieles andere noch, aber trotzdem Dead
3, ich muss euch auch ehrlich sagen, seitdem der Kram auf Youtube ist, krieg ich null mehr
mit von der ganzen Geschichte, juckt mich auch nicht mehr, die haben es voll verschissen,
Barbecue Pit Boys, ich hab Hunger Leute, nein nein, wenn ich mir das angucke, dann muss
ich jetzt off gehen essen, was, was hab ich denn da aus versehen angeklickt, ne, wer schaut
Streams auf Youtube, ja Blizzard bzw Youtube denkt das wahrscheinlich, weil die haben sich
ja die Rechte gekauft für dieses ganze Blizzard eSport Zeug da auf Youtube, aber es schaut
halt keiner mehr, Twitch haben viel mehr geguckt, musste ja überlegen, irgendein 0815 Counter
Strike, Regional, fragt mich nicht, Feldwald und Wiesentournament hat mehr Zuschauer als
die Overwatch League, ja, das ist halt echt der Witz, warte ich muss mal kurz, viewer,
ship Overwatch League, Moment, muss ich mir das mal angucken, eShackts, was für ein Dinger,
was ist das für ein scheiß Statistik, da sieht man ja gar nichts, die Chinesen sind
auch dabei, ja, man muss die normalen Spiele sich angucken, die haben dann irgendwie was,
weiß ich, 10k oder wenn es hochkommt, ne, immer noch besser als der Aldi Gaming, Moment,
du willst mir nicht ernsthaft sagen, es gibt Aldi Gaming auf Twitch oder, nicht Aldo, Aldi,
wait a minute, Moment, was es gibt, Aldi.gg, Moment, wirklich,
ist das irgendein, der Gaming Discounter, diese Gaming Bilder, sitzt ihr nicht auch immer so
mit dem Controller in der Hand, yeah, wow, geil, wäscht auf dem Fernsehseher, wow, ist
das toll, die gucken da immer so fake excited auf diesen Bildern, die Webseite ist scheiße,
die barkt rum, hallo, alter, top Spiele und exklusive Gaming Angebote, was, what the fuck,
zum Online Shop, ok, Aldi Gaming, Moment, was hat es damit zu tun, Aldi.gg, das macht
mich fertig, dass Aldi einen Gaming Kram hat, das macht mich irgendwie, verwirrt mich das,
ja, super Gaming Zubehör, ja, super Gaming Zubehör, was streamen die so, ja, ja, ja,
oh, Paynes Champ, was soll uns das denn sagen, eh
Das ist wieder sowas, wenn irgendwelche Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, junge Leute ansprechen
wollen oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, und warum genau haben die Aldi Gaming TV jetzt auf Twitch und, und sie machen da
drauf nichts?
Der Discounter Master Chief, ja, wenn man den Master Chief bei Wish bestellt, dann sieht
er so aus.
Was ist das mit einem, auf, Aldi, du hast so, na gut, warum nicht?
Na ja, was auch immer, soll mal Aldi, soll Aldi mal machen, ja?
Ich mein, warum nicht, man kann es ja mal probieren.
Ich werd, Leute, ich sag's euch, ich werd irgendwann mal, ich werd einfach Aldi Streampartner,
easy.
Und danach kommt noch Nettogaming.
Leute, sind wir wach?
Kaufland Gaming.
Sind wir wach, Leute, ich hab Hunger, ich muss unbedingt was futtern, ey, ich grad's
gleich ab.
Ich bin schon, ich bin schon gar nicht mehr fett, ich bin schon ganz dünn.
Otto Gaming, Neckermann Gaming, ich, ich, ich bin bald nicht, bald, bald gibt's mich
nicht mehr, so dünn bin ich schon jetzt, weil ich so viel Hunger hab.
Guck mal, ob ich irgendjemand hosten kann, ey, keiner da.
Also Leute, schön, dass ihr am Start wart, ich denke mal, ich werd den nächsten Tag jetzt,
wo mein, mein, ähm, Stromzähler-Bastelprojekt abgeschlossen ist, oder fast abgeschlossen
ist, die nächsten Tage wieder ein bisschen mehr streamen.
Den soll ich hosten.
Das sind Enten?
Alles, was nicht alles gibt.
Wir, wir hosten das, das, das Whirlpool Grill, ne, machen wir nicht, also Leute, wir sehen
uns, macht's gut, ich geh jetzt was vor, denn ich hab mega Hunger, bis denn, see you.